I'm talking to you. Listen, we're
back. I know it's been a while folks.
I know I've been super busy and I've
been down to one a week over the last uh,
couple of weeks, but almost out of
the woods with this new TV show.
So shit will get normal any
second now this week today, uh,
we have Marianna vans hour and a
Darren foster and then tomorrow,
Joey Diaz and I think we're going to
get mark Marin in this week as well.
So lots, lots of podcasts. You're
going to get annoyed with me again.
Then you start getting used to
me and then you'd be like, dude,
I'm tired of that show for right now.
This episode of the podcast is
brought to you by Squarespace,
squarespace.com. Forward Slash Joe is
where you want to go to check it out.
And if you've never heard of Squarespace,
it's an really excellent
website building platform.
It makes it super easy for dummies
like me to make a website. Uh,
if you've ever tried to like use
html and formulate your own website,
like they have to do that back
in the Caveman candle light days,
that's at least have to do.
Now you can make a really nice website,
really easy,
including setting up an online store,
which is ridiculously easy. You can
choose from over 20 excellent designs.
It looks super professional.
I mean, no bullshit.
If you go to these websites that you know,
show you how to design your own and the
amount of time that you would have to
put in to develop something that you
could develop super quick and easy on
Squarespace, uh, it'll
blow your mind. It's very,
very user friendly,
very intuitive.
And if you go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe,
you can try it out without using any,
you don't have to enter in
your credit card information.
You don't have to pay any money.
You can actually build a website first.
That's how confident they
are. And if you like it, then,
then you can use the code named
Joe and the number seven seven,
which stands for July. So
Joe and seven, all one word,
and you will save yourself 10% off
your first purchase. Go check it out.
It's excellent.
Squarespace's everything you need
to create an exceptional website.
And uh,
we are also brought to you by audible.com
audible.com is the leader in online
audio content. If you've
ever been, uh, you would, uh,
you'd be amazed at all the different books
and podcasts and radio shows and they
have so much content on
there the easily by far,
the strongest amount of content online
when it comes to audio podcasts,
there's over a hundred thousand
different titles, excellent books,
and it's a great way to spend your time.
Like if you're commuting or if you're
on a plane or something like that,
it takes wasted time and transforms it
into something either educational or
entertaining.
And if you use the code name,
if you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you will get one free audio book and 30
free days of service to check it out.
So that's audible.com forward slash Joe,
we're also brought to you
by [inaudible] dot com um,
for those of you saw the UFC last
night where we're going to try to start
sponsoring UFC fighters.
Um, but uh, that's uh,
that's gonna take a little bit of time.
We've got to work out some
of the details for that. Uh,
but I know a lot of you want
me to talk about the UFC.
We will talk about that tomorrow.
Joey Diaz is going to be here and uh,
he came to Vegas with me Friday night,
so he was there for the show
that we had at the joint.
Thanks everybody who came out to that.
And we will talk about
everything tomorrow.
That's probably same time tomorrow on
it.com is a human optimization website.
We sell at [inaudible] Dot com is
essentially everything you need as far as
health and fitness. Um,
we sell actual foods,
like we have a hemp force bars and
ham force protein and a tonka bars,
which are actually buffalo delicious
stuff. All like healthy things,
Himalayan sea salt and upgraded MCT oil.
And we also sell a lot of
fitness equipment if you're
into like kettle bells and
battle ropes and things along
those lines. Uh, medicine balls.
And the idea of the site is to provide
you with strength and Fitnii fitness
strength and fitness equipment as well
as supplements that give you human
optimization like Alpha brain,
which is a,
a nootropic blend of various nutrients
that are known to help aid in mental
function. Also have a Melatonin
and things along those lines.
I'll just like the healthiest shit that
we could find. All things that I use a,
and if you go to [inaudible] dot
com and use the code named Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all
supplements. All right. Freaks.
We got to get rolling here. I know these
commercials are too long sometimes,
so I'm trying to correct that.
Cue The music,
the Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
So, uh, with me today are, uh,
Darren foster and Marianna
von Zeller. And, um,
I first found out about
Marianna from the show, uh,
on vanguard, the Oxycontin
Express, which, uh,
I remember watching it in my house and
thinking this is the craziest thing I
have ever heard in my life.
I couldn't believe that all the things
you were telling me about the whole
system of pain management centers and
how it's set up in Florida, it was true.
And the statistics on how many
people are addicted to Oxycontin,
how many prescriptions are being given
out for Oxycontin in Florida is just
absolutely bananas.
And I watched an I and I said,
this is so far beyond out of control
that it's amazing that I'm just hearing
about it now from a documentary
on current TV, which is like,
you know,
not the most widely viewed channel.
I mean I felt like this
should be on every channel,
on the front page of every newspaper.
There's a hijack and going on down there.
They've hijacked the legal system somehow
or another and absolutely willfully
put these things into position in
order to extract money and do it at the
expense of all these people
being addicted. I mean,
how did you find out about this and
how did you go about doing that piece?
It's interesting you say that. I
mean, it was exactly the same for us.
The same surprise that we got when
we started looking into the story,
we found a little news clipping on one
newspaper about some deaths in Florida
because of prescription drugs.
And some of them were more pain clinics
around and Mcdonald's. And we thought,
wow, this is really interesting.
We should investigate this.
And we started looking into it and
then we found out that there were seven
people every day dying from prescription
pill abuse that all over the u s are
more people dying from a prescription
pill, overdoses and heroin,
cocaine and ecstasy combined that just
last year it's surpassed car accidents to
become the number one cause of
accidental deaths in the United States.
So this was the story that we could just
going to turn our heads away from mine.
God, when, when I watched it,
I went to work and I told all
these people about it. I was like,
you gotta see this. This is crazy.
And they, they didn't believe me,
like when I was saying I go,
do you know,
in Florida you can go to a doctor and
get a prescription and then they don't
have a database.
You can go to another doctor across the
street and get a new prescription and
just ping pong your way back and forth,
down the highway and they're everywhere.
You know,
the most insane thing was that we spoke
to the local journalist who had sort of
covered this story a little
bit and they told us, look,
you'll go by pain clinics here and you'll
see lines of people and out of state
cars parked outside and
literally lines of people,
I mean very long lines around the corner
of people waiting to get into these
pain clinics to get these prescription
drugs. And we thought, okay,
this is the kind of thing
that you hear about.
We'll never be able to film worth
witness ourselves. And then,
and then it was easy. I mean we,
as soon as we left the airport,
went straight to this one street that
we knew had a lot of pain clinics and
there it was, the parking lot's
full of out of state plates.
I mean people driving all
the way from Kentucky,
Ohio as far off as Massachusetts down
to Florida to buy their pills and they
pack their car with Pete cars with people,
and then they bring them
back and sell them for five,
10 times the price that they buy
them in Florida. So it's a racket.
It's so hard to believe when, when,
when I watched your show, it was,
it was so hard to wrap my head around
the fact that there was one area that was
so completely out of control because
where I grew up on the east coast or here
in California,
I've never seen anything like that and
I never had any inkling that this was
something that had to be dealt with
somewhere. So watching that was a, wow,
you really freak me out.
It was when we tried to film
one of the lines when you,
there was this one pain clinic that had
that, a lot of people like going to,
because it was super easy to get drugs
basically you just go in and out and get
whatever you wanted.
And we started filming outside and we
set our tripod and we were across the
street on the other side of this. Um, sort
of, it wasn't a freeway was sort of a,
a big street. And uh, as soon
as we started filming these,
these guys come out and they start
chasing us and they asked us what we were
doing and we said, you know, we were just
filming out here. Big Guys, big guys,
I mean big, big guys. Um, and um,
they started chasing us and we ran out
of gas cause every time he's tried to
stop and get gas in our car,
we were running low.
They would get out of the car and it was
just me, Darren and our other producers,
Teresa and I was freaked out the night
before I'd been watching the sopranos and
I really felt like I was apart of the
soprano's. I felt, Oh my God, we've been,
we traveled all around the
world and warzones and we're
going to be killed right
here in Florida,
in Fort Lauderdale,
Florida because we were
filming a pain clinic. It was,
but those guys, those guys were
actually later indicted. They were, um,
busted by the DA and
they were late indicted,
but in the indictment that found that
the head made like $40 million in two
years off these pain clinics and they're,
they're in jail for like 17 years now
because I think one of them was even, um,
convicted of like hiring someone to,
to, uh, kill to take out somebody else.
Yeah. Gun for hire. I mean,
these were dangerous people.
These were not people that you
yes or no. Not good people always
getting in behind the, these Iraqi.
So when you ran out of
gas, what happened? Yeah.
Until we ran out of gas
and I had just entered,
we just interviewed some line
forcement there and we had,
he was calling nine one one I was
calling the contact that we had for law
enforcement there and
saying please help us.
We don't know what to do and
it means I'm the nine one one.
I mean that we were about five
minutes later we were on a nine to five.
And so like highway patrol just saw that
we were pulled over anyway and they,
they came and then,
but we stopped and then the other guy
stopped behind us and they didn't come out
of the car cause I think they realized
that we were calling nine one one but
they just, they just stayed there
and it was just to intimidate us.
So they stay there and then they'd made
the story up to the police that uh,
we had been stalking,
stalking them,
that they had an ex girlfriend
that was talking them.
So they thought that we were stock,
they ex girlfriend or something.
But it's pretty warm too, bro.
She's filming cause she wants,
I mean you do have stalker
tendencies coming from my husband.
Wow. So, um, the non database thing,
that has to be a criminal thing.
I mean there's no way that
I could in this day and age,
there's no way that could be by accident.
Right?
Yeah. You know, they, they did pass a, um,
a drug control plan.
There they are now that is in place.
What does that mean?
It means that now doctors,
they have a database and plan but in,
in place basically that they are
supposed to check to see if a customer is
coming or a client is coming to get
more drugs so that you can't go what's
called doctor shopping from pain clinic,
pain clinic or pharmacy to
pharmacy to get all these meds. Um,
however it's not mandatory,
but I mean it's far better right now in
Florida than it was back when we went.
And what's happening with them?
Mandatory.
Yeah. I mean it all has to do
like these privacy laws, you know,
like they don't want your medical records
to be accessible to the government
basically. Right. And so, you
know, people that are very,
I guess worried about our
privacy, um, which, you know,
maybe we think about differently now
with the whole NSA scandal. Little.
I mean like, you know, people
are definitely, um, that's,
that's the resistance to,
to do in the prescription monitoring
programs and a lot of places.
But most states have them these days.
Florida was one of the biggest states
that didn't have one for a long time. Um,
but now with the,
obviously you know,
so many people dying of this and there's
the sort of bad reputation in the state
was getting, um, they
decided to do something
press down a little bit,
but it's still happening.
And two years after we did
that Oxycontin Express,
we actually were filming a story about
heroin abuse in Massachusetts and how,
because of the oxycontin
epidemic, a lot of kids, um,
then went on to do heroin for whatever
reason because oxy was getting more
expensive or it was harder
to get their hands on oxy.
So then they started shooting up heroin
because the effects are sort of the same
on, on the, on the body. Except, you know,
it's a street drugs in many ways
it's extremely dangerous as well. Um,
and so we actually went to a guy's house
who was selling heroin and he said,
dude, I'm selling hearing, but what I
really like to sell his spills and we,
we go down,
me and my friends all go down to Florida
and get a bunch of these and we make
much more money.
Our profit margin is much higher by
selling pills and it is selling heroin.
So we much prefer to that. Wow. Yeah,
that's hilarious. It's
pretty 2013. It's uh,
it's really shocking to me that that
hasn't been addressed and that you're not
seeing people talk about
that in the mainstream media.
Like the president never get fields
questions on the prescription pill problem
this country. And why is this
happening and have you investigated?
What factors are involved here or
they're dirty doctors. Are there,
are they in cahoots with the
pharmacy companies? Like, what,
how is it possible that there's,
they did a thing on Montana
recently in the Montana,
the billings daily gazette or something
that one of the billings daily
newspapers where they said
that out of 1 million people,
it Montana 240,000 new
prescriptions had been written.
Well,
I mean it's one of the things
that definitely drew us to that,
to see that story and to, to follow up
stories that we've done subsequently is,
is the fact that,
you know,
like we spend billions of dollars
every year fighting a war on drugs,
just trying to prevent drugs
coming into this country.
But meanwhile it's the drugs that
are being made in this country, um,
that are causing the biggest,
you know,
problems in terms of lives
lost and stuff like that. Yeah.
The war on drugs is playing cowboys
and Indians and pretending you're doing
genocide.
I mean,
is the worst job ever of controlling
drugs that anybody's ever done ever.
When you stop and think about how much
resources to results, it's so damn stupid.
It's like all you're doing
is arrest in pot dealers.
Why don't you just call it the war on
people probably won't shoot you and you
can make arrests. You
make them count. You know,
how many people were they arresting
that are involved in these pill clinics?
How many people they're investing that
are in involved in the pharmaceutical
companies. So obviously bribing
local lawmakers to make these laws.
I mean that's,
that is one of the creepiest state
laws I've ever heard in my life.
But it's not surprising that
it's coming from Florida.
Like if you wanted to have a crazy place
where you would think that that would
go, you go. Yeah. Yeah. I always say
the Florida is like the South Mexico,
you know, like we always look at
Mexico like, oh those God Mexico,
he think about all the crime that goes
on there and all the craziness and the
shenanigans we always look at like
Florida is like the south is that part of
this country and the Florida
is like that to the south.
Like they'll like Jesus Christ Florida.
Yeah.
Whenever it was stuck for a story where
he's like, what's going on in Florida?
If it wasn't for Florida, Nancy Grace, it
have nothing to talk about. It's a crazy,
crazy place right.
Now,
when you guys aired this and you,
you put this with,
was there any resistance? Did people
give you a hard time about this?
No, actually it's been an
incredible in the past,
I mean this air to three years
ago already and I still get, um,
weekly I get emails or Facebook messages
or people reaching out because they've
been somewhat, they've watched this and
somehow they've been affected by drugs,
by prescription drugs. You
know, their son has died,
their husband is addicted and they
reach out. Um, because this, this,
this documentary has made an impact on
them and they, um, and they want to,
to let us know, which is fantastic.
You know, as a, as a journalist,
that's the best kind of gift you can get.
Yeah. That's beautiful. Now you guys
did an amazing job. Like I said,
you completely enlightened
me on the subject.
I had literally no idea before I saw
your show that this was even an issue.
I had thought about, you know, people
need pills, like they get hurt.
And then I remember reading the
rush limbo thing and I'd be like,
that crazy bastard. Like,
what the fuck is he doing?
He's taking like 99 a day or
something nutty. Like that wasn't a,
do you know that number?
I don't know the number, but
I know some people, you know,
that we've interviewed have, you
know, gotten quite tolerant to the,
to the pills and they could take a
huge number, like a surprisingly,
a huge number.
He was going with his housekeeper.
He was having his housekeeper go
around and collect them for him.
And then apparently that's how he
got popped. The whole thing was just,
I was like, well, this
just this crazy fat guy.
Of course he's got a skeleton or two
in his closet. That guy's an asshole,
you know, like he's so judgmental and
evil and the way he goes after, you know,
all these, uh, the, the liberals and
the Democrats, I was like, of course,
that guy's fucking crazy.
Of course he's on pills.
Then when you hear that he did
so much that he lost his hearing?
Like somebody had to describe
it to me in medical terms.
He did so much oxycontin
that he blew out his hearing.
Wow. I mean, I don't know if you remember,
but the tod, the main guy in our, in our,
in our documentary, the oxy
got an express. He was this
kid, he was 28 at the time,
but he started doing oxies 10 years
before he lost his brother to Oxycontin.
He lost his wife to bills
and you could see, I mean,
and recently he died last year
as well, um, from drug overdose.
And you know, you could tell just
by talking to him, to him that he,
his mind was just not there and his, his
mom was constantly telling us like she,
he couldn't remember things.
He,
he was totally fried and it
was all because of pills,
the amount of pills he was doing
and he was taking an insane amount.
I remember him telling us,
what was it like,
you remember the teen 80
milligrams or that would just,
I don't remember lead you consulted a
doctor afterwards and told him how much
this guy was taking and he couldn't
believe it. He said that, you know,
obviously if any of us decided
to take that amount today,
we would die in a second because
we just don't have that tolerance.
Yeah. I have, uh, one of my, well I had
one of my best friends died from it, um,
that and actual heroin and uh, you know,
a bunch of other things and he was doing,
but it was just,
I've seen people caught in the grips of
physical addiction and it's a terrifying,
terrifying thing. I've never
experienced it myself. Um,
I, the only thing that I've,
that I've ever taken that's really
addictive as coffee and, um,
I guess alcohol to certain people, but
although it's never been to me, um,
but I've always been terrified of
the actual addictive properties.
It's something becoming
a part of your system,
not an impulsive addiction like gambling,
which I'm scared of that stuff too. Um,
cause I'm a very impulsive
person, but the, the,
the terrifying notion of
seeing it get into your bones,
which is what these pills do and it's,
it's so just evil.
Like it's almost like
vampires in a pill form.
It just slowly sucks your life away
and absolutely forces you to take it.
You know,
I'm from Europe,
from Portugal and in Europe it's only
prescribed to critically ill cancer
patients.
So it's,
it was so surprising to me to see
how easily they're prescribed here.
Yeah. That's because well it's because
of money. I mean it has to be. I got um,
my nose fixed.
I had a deviated septum and my doctor
gave me a prescription afterwards over of
two different types of
painkillers and I told them I go,
it doesn't even hurt because it,
it really didn't hurt.
Like everybody had told me, it was
like incredibly painful and all my God,
you're barely going to be able to deal.
Then I got out of there, I was like,
this is it. I was like, I
feel like I have a stuff nose.
Like it doesn't hurt at all.
And it was because my nose has been
packed with these things, but he was like,
you need pain pills. And
I'm like, listen man,
I just got done telling you that I'm
not even in pain. What did he give you?
He gave me vicodins and
I think it was percocets.
I didn't take it though, but I
just threw the prescriptions. Why?
I'm scared of that shit. Um,
I have a buddy who had a, um,
a problem with drugs and then he had
back surgery and then after he had back
surgery, they put them on pills, you know,
to give him one. And they're like, look,
you need prescription medication.
They didn't even take into consideration
the fact that he used to be a junkie
and so immediately as problem again, you
know, it was all shady and weird now.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, the unfortunate,
it's the way it starts with so many
people is it that they're an injury.
And that's why you see like
in a lot of places where the,
where the problem is is that it's
around places that have like a lot of
workplace injuries like evaled Aisha
where people worked at the mines and stuff
like that or get like closer to that.
Sorry. Yeah, sorry. Yeah. Uh, yeah.
So I mean that's a lot of times
where we see these clusters of,
of people who have, uh,
uh, become addicted.
Yeah. And it's, so, unfortunately, it's
like that is where, you know, you're,
you're finding these lower income people,
middle class people who worked
factory jobs and have to move things,
manual labor type jobs.
And it just seems like they have no hope.
Like once they get caught up in that,
it's so hard to get out from under the
grip of that monster and they don't have,
they can't afford to take a month off
and go to Malibu to some clinic where
they're going to feed them green
tea and rub their feet. You know,
like people are, they get, they're doomed.
Like you can get stock and the amount of
willpower required to pull yourself out
of that mud is insane.
It is.
I mean,
we spoke to so many people who
were getting better and they,
we really, I mean they really, they
had this conviction that they were,
this was it.
They were talking to us as,
as x drug addicts and they were
never going to take pills again.
And I would say that 99% of
those went back to drugs.
Did you know this is a statistic that
somebody put on my message board? Um,
a dude named evil homer. Thanks
Eva Homer, that last year,
five pharmaceutical companies were agreed
to pay 5.5 billion to resolve the US
Department of Justice
allegations of fraudulent,
fraudulent marketing practices,
including the promotion of medications
for uses that there were not approved by
the food and Drug
Administration. Insane. I mean,
if you go back and look at the
numbers that they've been paying,
like Pfizer in 2009 was fine.
2.3 billion.
And this is so many of them.
There's Glaxo Smith Kline,
3 billion and it's not, the pharmaceutical
drugs haven't done great things.
There's amazing applications
for pharmaceutical drugs
that have changed people's
lives for the better. Yeah. It's
just so unfortunate that it's a, uh,
it's the bottom line over morality,
over humanity.
The bottom line being ones and zero's
collect as many as you can above humanity
and it's,
it's not necessary.
It's like there's plenty of
valid applications for drugs,
but if you want to control the entire
world and you want to be like the king of
the planet and have all the,
all the gold,
like the best way to do it is to be like
fuck people. Just treat them as little,
you know,
vampires sucklings and take as much blood
as he can while keeping them alive for
as long as he can until they eventually
run out of money or blood and then move
on to the next one.
We spoke to a doctor,
he was a rehab doctor and he told
us something really interesting.
I think it wasn't the end of the nineties
that the medical got together and they
decided that the best thing to do,
to treat pain was to really go at it
aggressively and have the lowest possible
tolerance to pain. So if, uh,
if there was any chance that the patient
would feel any sort of feign just
treated aggressively by giving them a lot
of drugs and he says there was a total
shift, uh, in the end of the,
uh, the nine, the 90s, wasn't
it Darren? End of the 19th,
I believe it was. And um, and that's
when pain pills started being dispensed.
It dispense much more liberally. And I
think at the time they didn't really,
really realize what this, you know, the,
the addictive side of this
and what this could do.
How is it possible though? How's it
possible that they could have not known?
I don't buy that. Like everyone's
known that from the time I was a kid,
I knew that people had
problems with quail.
Ludes you would hear
about that all the time.
I didn't even know what a quail lewd was,
you know,
but I remember people always on Ludes,
the guy's got a problem with ludes.
So of course they knew
they're full of shit.
They must've bowed down to pressure
from the pharmaceutical companies.
There must, must've been someone
to cut a deal and said, listen,
if you guys just prescribed a little more,
do you know how much money
were you going on Mac?
And we'll give you a little bit of
this, a little bit of that. People say,
well that doesn't happen. Well, here's
one thing that definitely does happen.
My wife, uh, her mom is a nurse and, um,
her mom was working at this clinic and
she would tell us about the drug reps and
all the things that drug reps
would do for the company.
They take the whole company out to
dinner to a really nice restaurant. Like,
you know,
nurses are on very reasonable salaries.
Like they can't afford like a really
expensive restaurant or really a fine
restaurant. They'll take everybody
out by them, all the drinks,
order anything on the menu,
lobster and steak and this and that.
And they did it on a regular basis.
They gave them trips and all sorts of
other things and they made it everybody
like really eager to prescribe these
drugs, get to keep the drug reps around,
keep, keep the vacation's coming in, you
know, keep the lobster dinners coming.
It's amazing. Right. It's amazing.
And it's amazing that it takes
someone like you guys to,
to expose this like where's CNN,
where are these so called investigative
journalists that are supposed to be
looking out for us, you know, where are
the people that uncovered Watergate where,
where are the people that were
really looking out for America? Like,
what the fuck happened? What happened
to journalism in this country?
Well, I mean like for us, I
mean, you know, it's great.
Local reporting is what drew
us to the story. So, um,
they're all great reports but for some
reason, yeah. Some local guys, yes,
we have on the scene people on the
scene and like that's, you know,
we got the lead to this story and so,
um, yeah, why it doesn't get better.
National attention is a definitely a
question that I said we should all be
asking. Yes. Well it's
like w you know, you,
when you hear that the
CIA gives gigantic news,
corporations like Fox and CNBC gives
them talking points and that they follow
these talking points and then you hear
that these stories are going on and no
one's reporting it. Meanwhile,
they'll pay attention to, you know,
Kim Kardashians baby will be like the,
the lead on CNN,
Kim Guard ash hand.
Remember bird just harder.
And did they make it seem like that as
Florida is the fucking apocalypse parts
of Florida that like if,
if it was just a Zombie factory
and then people went in and turned,
came out as zombies, you'd be like,
oh well we have to stop this. They,
they're becoming zombies.
But did they are fucking becoming zombies.
They're becoming functional zombies.
Yeah.
Who can sort of walk around and live
amongst you as long as they keep getting
their Zombie medicine.
Yeah. We had that great sheriff in
our, in our doc say that, um, you know,
talk about these doctors
and how they were, uh,
what was it that he said there were
drug dealers, drug dealers with degrees,
which is such a great way of
fitting in. And they are, I mean,
they know what they're doing.
Right.
You, you, the other thing that you
exposed when you show these pains, Matt,
pain management centers
is that some of them,
they're actually connected to pharmacies.
Yeah. It is for, for folks would be,
first of all folks, if you haven't
seen the documentary, you must.
And where can they watch?
It isn't an online line where they get it.
You can actually go to [inaudible] dot TV,
which is mk.tv and you
seeK and u c k. Dot. TV.
It's our production company
and we have all our work there.
And the oxycontin
express is feature there.
Beautiful. It's a Mussy. It's
so enlightening. But the,
the pain management centers, you'd go
there and you say, hey man, my back hurts.
And they go,
well you definitely need some oxycontin
and just go three feet down the hall and
open up that next door.
And that's the prescription place.
And you go in there and the pharmacy
hooks you up and it's like one stop
shopping for drugs and it's
legal cash only cash, only cash,
only insurance, not that accepted cash
only. And so that's what happened to us.
We went,
we went undercover,
we put it,
you've got an undercover camera and went
into one of these and it was I think
the first pain clinic we went into.
And I just asked the receptionist so
I have a back pain, what can I get?
And she said, oh well they'll be
able to prescribe you oxycontin.
And she listed the,
the long list of drugs and you
just need to go get an Mri.
And basically what this is is that an MRI
can show anything and you can point to
something and say that
that's what's hurting you.
And did the doctors just need to see
something that they can then say, look,
I looked at the MRI and it
looked like she had that.
It was legitimate back pain
and that's all they need.
And so we went out the door to get this,
to get this MRI and we stopped and start
talking to these guys that had come to
get down from West Virginia and Kentucky
and they were telling us, you know,
we traveled down there here cause it's
just so easy to get these drugs and we
just say we have a back pain.
But of course we don't have anything.
We just want to take a lot.
A lot of these rugs back home with us when
people are listening to this and saying,
well how easy ready for this doctors
in Florida prescribed 10 times more
oxycodone pills than every
other state in the country.
Column bind.
Yeah,
red flags all around.
But if you smoked pot in Florida,
they'll put you in a cage son.
They would lock you up in a box,
throw away the key. What are your
damn hippie trail? Ruin your life.
You've got problems.
Go to the pain management clinic,
get a nice American cocktail of opiates.
The, have you guys ever seen the
documentary, the documentary,
the wild and wonderful
whites of West Virginia? Yes.
Beautiful and sad at the same
time and hilarious. Look,
if you can't do anything about it and you
just accept that going in, you have to,
you can't look at it and say,
Oh that poor child growing up
cause then you'll get all sad.
But if you can treat it as a comedy and
pretend to not real and treat it as like
if you're watching a Coen brothers movie,
a big part of that documentary is pills.
Yeah.
Huge part of what those people are.
And that culture of wild hillbilly white
trash crazy people is about is about
pill addiction. Yeah. We
spoke to some people in jail,
some women in jail that were in jail
because of pill trafficking from Florida
and they called themselves pill
billies. Yes. What a great name.
Hilda Hillbilly. Hillary and
heroin. Yeah. Appalachian. Yeah.
It's uh,
it's really confusing and it to,
to have it all exposed and one piece
like yours and just all of a sudden be
like, why? It's like that's out there.
It's was a real paradigm
shifting moment for me.
And it was the thing that really got me
paying attention to pills in general.
And then I started reading all
these other bizarre stories like,
I dunno if you've ever heard about
the man, um, who, uh, was awarded, uh,
the equivalent of 600,000
American dollars because a,
he was on a Parkinson's drug called a
Requip and this was by a Glaxo Smith
Kline.
They had this Parkinson's drug and it
turns him into a gambling and gay sex
addict who was a straight man and he took
this pill and it was Parkinson's drug.
So apparently it has some
psychoactive properties.
So that's something to
the way the mind works.
And all he wanted to do was
have gay sacks and gamble. Yeah.
Brilliant.
But I mean he got 600,000,
so it's not like just an accusation,
it's an accusation backed up by
at least some science. I mean,
I don't know what they use to show
that there's some sort of a chemical
correlation between his
activities and this drug,
but they pulled the drug off the market.
The drug doesn't exist anymore.
And so he got his $600,000
in gambling.
He got off the Parkinson's medication and
it became a straight man again without
a gambling problem. But with $600,000
in his pocket and a lot of bad memories.
A lot of horrible,
horrible gay sex gambling memories.
Yeah, it is weird. But it's just
how did, I mean they, there's,
there's so many drugs like
those late night things,
you know those commercials you
see for those shady legal guys,
two o'clock in the morning like did you
take phen phen in the eighties you know,
call this number and we will get
you the money that you deserve.
It's just shocking.
How easy is for these things to get
prescribed or for these things to get
approved. Like how much testing
is involved, do you, do I,
did you guys ever find out as far as like
how much testing is involved in making
something?
So the interesting thing is that when
all these pain pills start at being
produced,
such as Oxycontin,
they were really easy to manipulate
so that you can use them.
They have this time release.
Um, um, so that when you, you,
when you take a pill, they will
have an effect on your body,
but over time,
and that was really easy to manipulate
so that you would take it and it would
immediately have all the effect at once,
which was,
which is what an addict
ultimately wants. Um, so then, uh,
they were heavily criticized for that.
So then they came up
with a pill that was it.
So easy to manipulate and um, but
then, you know, that was easy. They,
they found a way around that to, addicts
found a way around that too. And we, we,
you just go online and you search how to
manipulate. Then you walk sees and it's,
you put them,
there were ways,
I remember addicts telling us that you
just put them in a microwave and do all
this certain kinds of things.
And I'm not going to say here because
I'm not trying to get people to do it,
but that, that there are ways
to manipulate every line.
So even when they try to
play it safe, um, you know,
there's always a way
around it for an addict,
why are they smoking them?
Yeah, just, I mean it's the quickest way
to get it into your body to adjust it.
You get it all at once,
you know,
it just same as snorting and
crushing and snorting end.
Did you just get it all at once?
Like Marianne was saying,
it was initially made as a time release
formula so that it would sort of fall
out over eight hours, 12 hours, something
like that. But if you crush it and just,
nor did you get all the active ingredient
once all the oxycodone at Watson.
Thank you Darren. You were much better
at explaining that is having a hard time,
but as soon as what people
like freebase cocaine, right,
or small crack and stuff
like that. It just, yeah,
it's um, it's, it's really kind of a
brave new world type thing, isn't it?
It really is sort of a, a horrific version
of the future thing. These numbers,
like especially the,
the Florida number of 10 times the number
of prescriptions for oxycodone on the
nene tire country combined. I thought
before I read it like I saw, I bet.
I Bet Florida is certainly number one,
but probably only about like 50%
or something like that. That's,
that was my silly little idea 10 times.
I think there's also a number that the,
the,
uh,
there are a hundred doctors at most
prescribed Oxycontin in America or 99 of
them are in Florida or
something like that, which is,
Ooh, Ooh, powerful Florida.
What's that? Yeah. Back. Yeah. Back
then. It's changed somewhat now. Yeah.
But you know,
I'm torn on these things because a part
of me is I'm a huge fan of personal
freedom and I'm a huge fan of
civil liberties and I think,
I think if you want to be
an idiot and ruin your life,
you should be able to be an
idiot and ruin your life. And I,
there's a lot of things that would
ruin some people's life that I enjoy.
Like whiskey. I like whiskey. I
like, like having a couple of shots,
but I'm not a drug addict
and I'm not an alcoholic,
so I can have a couple shots of
whiskey and stop and that's it.
I don't need them every
day. And I, you know,
I can do it once a year
if I really wanted to,
but I'm also really keenly aware that
I don't know what I'm talking about
because I've never done an opiate.
Did you guys ever consider
trying it? Yes. No, no, no.
Um, you know, we, we, we,
we, we like to immerse
ourselves in stories, but not
that far. Yeah. Yeah. We went,
we went to Brazil for example. We did a
story about the Campbell frog. Uh, we did,
we did it would say a drug that does
all this sort of things to your blood
stream and it's supposed to be really
good for you. But, um, it's, it's crazy.
It's the skin of a frog that gets dried
and then you punctured a little hole in
your body and you put the skin
there, uh, the skin of the frog,
of the secretion of the frog. And then
it gives you sort of a burst of energy.
You feel your blood coming up and down,
all over your brain.
It seems like your brain
is about to explode. Um,
and it has a lot of pharmaceutical
promise. This, um, this,
this particular frog Campbell
Campbell for, okay. How actually,
how do you spell that? K. A.
N. B. O. K. And that's it.
And it's beautiful frog.
It is actually a beautiful giant,
really green for Alagan. Yeah. So it
creates this chemical, um, and it's,
you know,
sort of slimy that slime they take and
they dry it out and then they, yeah,
they do like a crude injection of
like burning you. So it's the, the,
the native drives down there that
they use it as sort of like a, uh,
or a cleansing ritual,
but it doesn't,
it's not hallucinogenic or anything
like that. It, it just, um, but what,
what attracts like medicine to
it is that it breaks the, the,
the blood brain barrier. So it's
like, I dunno what that exactly means,
but it's very attractive to science,
but they haven't figured out
how they're going to use it yet.
I think it's going to be good for heart
disease to treat heart disease. Wow. Yeah.
And so that was, uh, we, we definitely
immersed ourselves. It's not a tough one.
I don't think
it's another sign of how
crazy human beings are.
This one spot in the world like Brazil,
the rain forest where there's so much
promise as far as like new healing,
new plants that can do
all sorts of great things.
And what are they doing
to just sharpen it down?
Just hacking it down at a record pace.
It's insane. We've done several stories
about that and it's just insane.
It's so sad.
Every time we go back,
so many different wonder cures have
been found in, in the rain forest.
Like they're always looking for the
rain forest to come up with a new new
medications for all sorts of things.
And you know,
there's the good side of the
pharmaceutical companies,
the fact that pharmaceutical companies
are creating things that are helping keep
your grandpa around for longer and
you know, and keep people healthy.
It's such a double edged sword.
And like I said, for me it's,
I'm so torn because I would,
I don't think that I would want to be
in a neighborhood where they're selling
heroin,
but I don't think that anybody should
be able to tell anybody else they can't
buy heroin.
But then you get into that area of the
addictive properties of it and that's
where it gets sketchy. That's
where it gets like, well,
if you're going to do anything
as a community to try to
stop something like that,
boy, there's, there's not a lot of ways
you can convince people to not do things.
It's very difficult and it gets real
weird when you're trying to convince
someone to not do something that has a
really good chance of ruining your life.
Absolutely.
And I know you talk a lot about drugs and
I don't know if you've looked into the
portrait piece experience.
I'm from Portugal and Portugal,
basically one of the biggest experiments
in drug policy in the world and it
Meson for 10 years and it's
actually quite a success rate.
And what they did is they did
to claimant decriminalize drugs,
they didn't legalize them,
they decriminalized them.
Meaning that if you're caught where
they think it's one gram of heroin or
cocaine,
100 gram of heroin,
two grams of cocaine or 25 grams
of marijuana, if it's anything,
if it's that or less, you don't go to
jail as you as you do in other countries.
And what they do is they send you to a
drug Rehab Commission and to a group of
doctors that know what
they're talking about,
that want to find out if this is the
first time you're trying drugs and why are
you doing them.
And they try to address the problem
as a disease and not as a crime.
And it's had actually great success
rate and a much less people are going to
rehab centers,
much less people are dying.
So it's definitely being looked at as um,
as a way to go in terms of drug policy.
Well, that's a beautiful idea
also in terms of human nature,
because it's human nature to not want
to be controlled. There's, there's many,
many examples and if you have children,
you know that if you know one of the
best ways to get a kid to want to do
something, just tell them
they can't do it. It's a,
it's a natural human tendency to try to
resist and when you tell them they can
do whatever they want and the old you'll
be there to help them like you're,
you're honestly better off.
And we would like to think that the
established laws that we have in this
country are set up to protect people,
but they're clearly not.
When you're dealing with these numbers,
especially outside of Florida,
like I told you about billings,
Montana newspaper,
talking about 240,000 different
prescriptions for that stuff in,
in Montana alone, it's obviously
not the case. This is not,
it's not that anybody is
trying to look out for anybody.
It's just simply a matter of a
crazy system where it's become this,
there's this weird sort of method that
you can do to skirt logical thinking and
extract money from,
from humans and,
and you can do it in
this is a really immoral,
horrible way by getting them addicted to
these things and the fact that doctors
are in on it. That's what the, that's
the weirdest aspect of it, that,
that these people who
supposedly had dedicated their
lives to helping people and
that's what their whole
career was supposed to be,
improving the health of people,
keeping people alive and then somewhere
along the line in the whole storm of
student loans and,
and,
and getting sued for malpractice
and all this different shit, they,
they somewhere along the line of bunch
of them just crack and they just go,
let's just make some money.
Yeah.
We spoke to some addicts
in a Florida who's doctor?
The one that the doctor prescribed
them. The drugs was, and this was a kid,
actually a boy, a man, a 25
year old kid was a gynecologist.
So he was going to a gynecologist
to get his meds. Whoa. Well,
if anybody would know.
Wow, that's so crazy.
This story is also close to me
because besides my friend who died,
I had another family member that
had nothing wrong with them.
He was a completely normal,
great guy,
and then got injured in a work accident
and became the biggest fuck up I have
ever met in my life.
And it's,
it's hard for me to even imagine that
this is the same guy I knew from high
school. He was a, at one point
in time as a hard worker.
He was a great kid.
He was always friendly.
And then he just became a
complete loser of compulsive liar.
Anything you could do to get
bills. And, uh, so I, I've,
I've seen the first hand affects of
someone who didn't have an issue.
Like he didn't have any physical issues.
He also didn't have any
family history of people,
people being addicted to anything. So
it was just a monster got into a system.
I understand what you say that a person
should be able to get whatever they want.
If they're adults and they
can make up their own lines,
but they should also be able to know
what they're getting too many times the
problem, again, the
injuries, a big problems,
big reason why people get
into prescription drugs is
because they're prescribed
this by their doctor and there aren't
enough warnings as to how addictive this
stuff can be. And then, you know,
we spoke to one kid who was also a star
athlete in college and he was featured
in the second documentary we did about
this issue and he was in the hospital for
five days and he left us the hospital.
He was already addicted to pills and never
left. And I was shooting heroin. Wow.
It's so crazy. So this is
a story. I know a story.
So just imagine how many
stories there are out there.
Just people that get injured and get
addicted. And how do we stop this?
Is there a way, is it too far into
the, the, the cultural system?
I mean, is it a part of us now? I don't
think so. I think a lot, not more.
It needs to be done and they're fantastic
people out there. A lot of moms,
actually mothers was lost.
Kids who are leading the way and trying
to raise awareness and pass legislation.
I definitely think that
more needs to be done.
More doctors need to prescribe the US,
uh, know what they're prescribing and uh,
you know, uh, people know,
need to know more about what they're
being prescribed in the addictive
addictiveness of it. Wow. It's, um, it's,
to me it's one of the most
disturbing aspects of our culture.
It's one of the most disturbing.
It's second only to war know the idea
that there's this massive corporations
that are profiting off of these people
becoming zombies. It's, uh, it's really,
really crazy.
So I want to thank you very much for doing
that document because you guys really,
you knocked it out of the park and
he changed the way I look at it.
So this new show you're doing,
it's called a inside secret America.
It's on Nat Geo. And does
it aired yet? Does it start?
It starts Wednesday night.
This one's day. This was in it
safety and that is the first episode. Oh,
awesome. And what is the show? What's,
what are you guys doing on the
first one is drugs from them.
I actually synthetic drugs.
So we look into sort of a bath salts
and spice and k two and all that stuff.
And the show is basically a Darren who's
my producing partner and my husband and
myself. We go around America exploring
an ill infiltrating these uh,
subcultures. Some of the West is most, um,
controversial subcultures and everything
from sex trafficking to unregulated and
illegal guns to the first episode,
which is about synthetic drugs.
Wow.
Did you guys follow the John Mcafee
case? Yeah, I made a little bit.
I saw the, the vice guys were down there.
Did you follow the drug aspect of it?
So I've heard about it, but I'm not like
to uh, up to speed on what was going on.
But I heard it was, he was like making
his own like stuff. Right. I have no idea.
Well that's awesome.
And this is the entrance of all fairness.
He says that it was all troll and then
he was just joking about the drug part.
But the reality is he had a laboratory
set up in his backyard in Billy's like a
real legit laboratory.
And inside that laboratory,
I don't know what he was actually doing,
but he made a post under a pseudonym
on this drug forum describing his
freebasing of bath salts. And his,
uh, he did some work with, I dunno,
I dunno what the technical aspects of his,
uh,
t is transformation of the bath
salts and the something else.
But he had claimed that it made you this
incredibly hypersexual a person and he
was trying to market it as like, like, uh,
he was trying to come up with a
drug that would turn women into like
Nymphomaniacs essentially doubled
the female Viagra. Yeah. Sort. SORTA,
but Viagra doesn't make you a raw.
Yeah, but, but you know what I mean?
Like vi Viagara is an aid to
a man achieving an erection.
But it doesn't necessarily make
you like a horny person. Right.
Whereas this was a a mental thing like
who change you, make you very, very,
very aroused and you know,
he did describes on the Webs,
his post is like,
you know,
clawing your genitals and like freaking
out masturbating all day. And I mean he,
he had these really detailed depictions
of the chemical transformation of these
drugs and clearly had
this massive laboratory,
well not massive but like really high
end high tech laboratory set up and his
crazy fucking jungle house. And this
guy was cooking bath salts back there.
I mean the doctors we spoke
to, he definitely said that
like hypersexuality is,
is one of the sort symptoms, not
symptoms. What the side effects,
side effects or benefits, benefits,
however you wanna describe it of Batsauce.
Yeah. And depending how you slice it,
I wonder who he was starting to think
for these drugs.
I know they're for women but with men by
these drugs to give to their wives and
girls.
Friends are always, well what
he was doing, it was good.
He had like a bunch of young
girls from this, you know,
it was Billy's a third world country.
I guess sort of developing the PC way.
So he had these,
you know,
young jungle girls like 20 years old
or however the where like I think his
girlfriend was 20. And
he was like, you know,
had all these pictures of these different
girls that he was getting hooked up on
bath salts. Crazy dude. We had him on the
podcast when he's actually on the run.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. After he
was being charged with murder,
he fled the country and he was calling us,
I think it was caused
from Mexico on a, um, uh,
one of those little Kmart cell phones
that you buy are very nervous. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. And so he was, he called into the
podcast and spoke to us for like an hour.
It was fascinating too.
We asked him about the drugs and he was
saying that you can't believe everything
you read. I am a notorious
Prankster, you know,
I think that was his, it's
just, just fun and hey,
I know that's how I prank when I prank
I set up a lab and a fucking do it
hardcore, man. I make you really believe
that I'm cooking bass off. Meanwhile,
I'm just back there with some like glitter
and glue and I mean he made like this
really like high resolution photographs.
It was work and detailed the whole
process. So if he was a troll, like man,
he's a really well thought out troll.
He's a, he's a character and a half.
But um,
the bath salts aspects where one of the
parts of the whole story where they just
sort of painted him like
this maniac. Yeah. Yeah.
Some of the names of these bath
salts are just insane. Yeah.
We were able to actually acquire some
just that smoke shops here in southern
California that were, one was
called Scooby Doo. The other one,
the sec called sexy Zombie.
And we need it.
We went into smoke shop and bought this
stuff. And then we were actually, uh,
so our first episode we actually filmed
some, um, uh, we feature some, uh,
a marine who's addicted to, or who was
at the time addicted to bath salts.
We should explain to people that these
are not actually bath salts to people
that live happy lives here. It's
drugs stay off the internet. Right.
The term bath salts as a term given
to these synthetic drugs that escape
regulation because they're not clinically,
they're not technically legal or illegal.
Illegal.
Yeah.
Undefined.
Well they're defined and they sell them
and sell them as bath salts and says not
for human consumption warrant warrant.
Right, right. Exactly. Yeah. So
there are chemical,
they're made in labs,
but they have the same sort of effects
on your body as a cocaine or math,
but it's made in labs so there's nothing
natural about it is entirely made with
chemicals,
most of which come from China and India
and you can order them and then you have
a garage and they're the kids.
This is how it started off with these
kids putting all these chemicals together.
You have it all the internet step by
step on how to make it pretty easy.
And you make these batches of both what
they call bath salts and the initially
call them bath salts so that they
could sell them with a not for human
consumption.
We went blank,
although they're super expensive
compared to regular bath salts and you,
and they may be a spice and k two and
these were drugs that were sold over the
counter smoke shops. I mean we were
able to buy them at shell stations,
gas stations,
and they're sold all over the country.
And it's really hard to go after these
drugs because as soon as the government
comes out and prohibits one
compound, they immediately, you know,
China and India is already have already
all these other chemicals ready to ship.
Um, so they just need to change a little
compounds and it's a new drug and it's
legal all of a sudden.
So that's why it's so hard to get.
It's, it's amazing that that
sort of popped up out of nowhere.
It's like all of a sudden someone figured
out, oh, we could do this. Yeah. Well,
I think they would like,
they were sitting around in like chemistry
labs at universities, like, you know,
they were doing legitimate research on
them. And then this sort of, you know,
monkey got out of the cage and next
thing you know, it's, uh, you know,
running ramp at 28 days later.
Really interesting.
It was a professor at a university in,
do you remember what the name of the
university was? A Michigan, maybe,
I can't remember, but it was a professor
in the 70s it was doing this research.
You wanted to know what kind of
effects drugs have on a person's brain.
So he was doing all this research and
came out with all these compounds and all
this came out. And
suddenly it was, you know,
tha tha tha tha tha tha instructions and
the manual on how to create these crazy
drugs that are now everywhere
around us and legal.
Yeah. But, but you know,
John McAfee, McAfee, McAfee,
McAfee,
I never know how to say that.
It always pops up on your computer and
you're like McAfee graded that, right? No,
he didn't create basketball,
McAfee viral software.
So He's, he's a legitimate, the smart
guy. Why is it one point in time? Yeah,
it might be a little crazy,
but like most of these bath salts and
synthetic marijuana of being put together
by like some Yahoo who's in the garage.
So that's where the problem
comes in is that, you know,
you don't know what you're getting and
you don't know how if they're mixing it
correctly, they do these things. You
get these things called hotspots,
like where at one portion of the batch
we'll have like 30 times the amount of
the product compared to another part
that might just have just been missing,
you know, so, so you never know what
you're getting. And obviously, you know,
when you have like a 1920 year old kid
who's just looking to make some money and
mixing it together, he's not probably
doing the best science to, uh, yeah.
Yeah. And you're also, there's a bunch of
different effects of these things, right?
It's another night.
It's not uniform.
Yeah, we did. We spoke about the over
aggressiveness. People believe that
they have superhuman force. Uh,
there's all these videos that you can
search it on youtube to have people going
out and believing their superman
and throwing themselves off cliffs.
We spoke to a doctor who had
treated a patient who was a lawyer.
He was studying for the bar and took
some of this stuff and decided that his
hands, his own hands, we're trying
to attack him. He thought paranoid.
He thought his hands were
trying to attack him.
So he put both his hands on a stove top
and burned his old art heart arms and he
couldn't feel the pain.
So it was just because the neighbor smelt
the burning of his arms that they came.
So he was cooking his own arms.
Just sitting is on arms.
Yeah. So some of these
drugs are related to, um,
other drugs where they like take it
and they change a molecule or twist
something around. But they're,
they're not, it's not uniform.
So it's not like they're all
derivatives of this. They're there.
They very like wildly.
So you buy a batch of sexy Zombie today
and do you snort it or smoke it and it
does something to you really like it's
a really great high, it wasn't too bad.
Next day there's not much of a hangover.
So the next day you decided you want to
go to the smoke shop and buy some more
of this stuff. But that batch can
be, have the same name, same name,
possibly come from the same place, but
it's entirely different. You never know.
Every single batch is different.
So suddenly you might be taken to the
hospital or you might be out trying to
attack somebody.
And there's also that story in Florida,
that guy that ate that guy's face that's
felt on the map. That story. Yeah.
Well what's interesting is they
said, well it's been, you know,
it's been refuted because he didn't
test positive for bath salts.
But then I read there is
no test for bass salts.
Like he didn't test positive and passwords
cause it doesn't exist. You don't,
first of all, they don't know what to
look for. Right. Because it could be any,
a number one of these different
substances and second of all,
they're not looking.
Exactly.
And that's why they're so popular in
that we heard that they're so popular in
places where there's drug testing is,
is a mandatory searches military or we
have communities or even bull fighting.
We were in Arizona and interview both
people from the bull fighting community.
And this is really popular there because
it's so hard to test these drugs so
they can do that. Just take them and know
that nobody's going to ever find out.
So they take these bass sauce and then
hop on a ball. Yeah. Holy Shit Jacqueline.
Yeah. We spoke to a kid to
do that reckless person go.
It takes bath salts and
gets it. I'll pull. Wow.
So it's very possible apparently that
that guy who he, that guy's face was,
was on pass halls as possible. And
that sounds right. Right. Doesn't it?
It's uh, I guess, yeah, it's
consistent with behavior.
That's nice. Very scientific
words. Yeah. I mean we can't,
I have no idea if the guy was on
bath salts. It definitely, you know,
I think the cops were like, this is the
craziest thing you've ever seen. And it,
it's just consistent with behavior that
we've seen of other people that have
been on bath salts.
That's why that jumped to the conclusion
that maybe it was bath salts and even
after the autopsy or whatever
they did, you know, they, uh,
they said they ruled out that what that,
I don't know if they rolled it out,
but they said that it probably wasn't
bath salts or something, but who knows
how long before the pharmaceutical
companies realize how much money's in bath
salts and just say,
listen,
we need to do is just set up some labs
and like Mexico or Peru or whatever,
turn out our own bath salts, launch
them over the border with catapults,
have people pick them up on trucks.
Yeah.
Well there's an article that came out
today actually about how the DEA had just
busted and is really concerned about
synthetic drugs because it is becoming
quite a big problem here
in the United States.
And how they finding out that
actually it is, uh, they,
they said that it was their finding
some connections of how it's funding
terrorism in the Middle East.
It's funny how everything ends up.
Funding terrorism in the Middle East.
It just means we need to spend more money
on tanks. That's the tank companies,
you know. But there are some really
sad stories that we, you know,
we interviewed the father
of a kid who took baths,
holes for the first time because a
friend gave it to him and the kids went
totally wild.
Came into his parents house and slit his
throat in front of his parents and uh,
died five days later. Oh. So yeah,
it's definitely something to,
well, when you have children, that's
when drugs really start worrying you.
Like drugs never worried me when I was
single because I was like, you know,
I'm not doing anything stupid.
I'm not worried about it.
I would hear stories about people dying
and you know, it would make me sad,
but it didn't, it didn't hit
home. Boy started having children.
And you think about all the dumb things
that you did growing up and somehow or
another dodge,
all those bullets and got to be an adult
and you think about these little ones
growing up in this new world where it's
not so easy because when I was a kid,
there was no such thing as oxycontin.
There was no such thing as
pain management centers.
There's no such thing as 240,000 people
in a year getting a prescription for
oxygen in Montana. There was none
of those things. So those hurdles,
even though it was still, there's lots
of scary stuff that that wasn't there,
but I got really fortunate that I
saw my friends when I was a kid.
My friend's cousin was a coke dealer and
they go, I got to watch him right away.
I mean, I got to watch his life like
fall apart over the course of a year.
Like I lost all this weight became creepy.
He was hiding all the time.
Just became like a vampire.
Like he got bitten by a vampire and
became this like sick person was really,
he was a dealer. Yes, he was a dealer,
an addict himself who's doing it himself.
And in watching that and watching them
go from like a regular guy to becoming
this guy,
it was a huge lesson to be learned.
And um,
I was in Vegas this weekend and I heard,
I was talking to this guy who was
a, the the driver and I said, uh,
you know how you like living in Vegas? Is
it, is it problem? He goes, well, he goes,
you know, the thing is
a, it's the drugs man.
You gotta avoid the drugs if
you can avoid the drugs. It's a,
it's a good place to live. Like it's
like most people just avoid the strip.
But fortunately for me,
my sister was hooked on drugs and
southern person was hooked on drugs.
He's telling me all the people he knew
that are hooked on drugs, you know,
that had sort of, he learned from
them to not do it. It's like,
it's almost like how we need to learn.
You need to learn by watching
other people fucking okay. Yup.
You are going to leave the
belief that government,
if the government comes out and tells
you to avoid it, you're like, whatever.
Fuck you crux now you know,
it's w what can be done to like besides,
you know,
you talking,
are you doing a show like that?
Did you guys or is there anybody you
talked to that had some really concrete
plans or how this could be hard
now there's some great organizations out
there, support group or organizations.
You know, again, a lot of them are
being led by women, by mothers,
which I think is phenomenal and they
are really trying to raise awareness and
pass legislation to make these,
these,
these bills are harder to get into
to stop these, these, you know,
crazy doctors from over prescribing.
Um, but it's, you know, um, the, there,
there is a way and I,
I do love the,
whenever I speak to some of these mothers,
it's really refreshing to see these,
these are just women who are so
strong and wanting to fight for this.
Yeah, well that, that is a nice thing,
but it just sucks that they
have to fight for that. Jamie,
there's something going on with it.
It's buffering every few minutes.
People complain a lot. Yeah. So
you stream side. Yeah, yeah. Sorry.
We got a hundred megabytes a second
upload ladies and gentlemen now.
So it's all Ustream, those dirty
bitches. You gotta figure it out,
complained to use trim. We can't
help you. Um, the, uh, the, uh,
the show, you're going
to basically, you're,
you're going after a lot of
different things. It's not,
not just drugs. When you,
when you do this kind of investigative
journalism and you're like ruffle
feathers and sort of, uh, make noise.
Did you guys experience
any blowback from that?
Um, occasionally, but then, you know,
like this series as we did in the
Ashcan p said that we started with, um,
you know, we did some on a lot of, on
the cover of filming and uh, you know,
our sort of approach to that is that
we're not looking to get any individual in
trouble when I try to do any Gotcha. Kind
of journalism and busts any individual.
We're just trying to shed light on
an issue. And so I think, you know,
if we were targeting a specific
individual, um, you know,
there might be a little bit of blowback,
um, whether rightly or wrongly,
whether we were doing it that
way. But I think, you know,
the fact that we were just trying to
shed light on an issue and the only way
that we can do that is with
on the cover of cameras. You,
you sort of, uh, you know,
mute the blow back a little bit because
it's just enlightening for most people
to see what goes on when people don't
know the camera's rolling, you know?
Yeah. That's a, that's probably a very
good point. Yeah, I didn't think of that.
That's um, uh, that,
that's probably what saved you guys.
Well, Mike, well, Mike Wallace. Yeah.
From 60 minutes, 60 minutes pioneered
the undercover camera. Then they,
they started doing away with it and
Mike Wallace said, you know, uh,
the idea was to, to draw
light, but we started drawing
heat. And so once you know,
it just becomes a bit of a, you know,
during heat and not shedding enough light,
then, you know, it's not
time. It's time to sort of
stopped doing it. So yeah, I think that
will be our, or it's time to stop as well.
But I do get nervous every
time. I know, you know,
I just rewatched for the 10th time,
the doctor,
the first episode of this series that
is airing on Wednesday night at 10:00 PM
and I'm in a,
made me really nervous just to watch
some of the stuff cause we did go
undercover and filmed a lot of things,
films,
a lot of people selling drugs and
some people taking drugs and um,
a lot of it was filmed undercover and
makes me nervous for sure. But it's,
it an issue that we thought
was, you know, an important issue,
not enough people know about it.
And what other subjects you guys cover?
We have,
the second one is about guns.
Um,
and we go into, we go to Arizona.
We spent a lot of time in Arizona,
uh, and we basically became the, the, we
transformed ourselves into the bad guys,
into criminals trying to get guns
just to see how easy it would be for a
criminal to get their hands on guns in
Arizona. And in the space of about two,
three days, we were able
to get three handguns, uh,
one of which is the most powerful handgun,
a Smith and Wesson 500 magnum. I know.
I now I'm an expert on guns.
I knew nothing about guns before this
and we were able to get an AK 47 and a 50
cow caliber, which is know most
powerful names in the world. Um, out of,
um, the, the, the AK 47 we got out of the
Taco bell parking lot. We went online,
um,
backpage.com re looked for AK 47 and
within 45 minutes we had bought an AK 47
out of those guys.
Is this car as well? Oh my God.
We were on a budget so we can,
so this person, when you ere
the, showed you blocked her face,
black, their faces out. Because who knows
why they're doing this and that case,
they actually looked
like drunk drug addict.
So it was really important for
us to not, again, not knowing,
going after anyone personally.
Yeah. Beautiful of you. And
congratulations on handling it that way.
Cause that's a,
I think the the right way to do it.
And it's also obviously this person as a
part of a much greater issue in to turn
it on to make it about one person.
It's like,
it's a tendency to do in this country I
to victimize or to criminalize this one
person or whatever,
you know,
focus on one person when really
what's going on is the issue, right?
Being able to buy cons that easy.
Do you know what's so interesting though
is that right after we bought that AK
47, it was, I think it was, uh,
it was a first assault rifle
that we bought in Arizona and uh,
we'd been nervous whether,
you know,
we'd invested money to go there and we'd
going to be able to, to buy these guns.
And so to sort of celebrate our
purchase, we went into the, uh,
bar right next to Taco bell and
we order three beers. Myself,
Darren and the other
producer, Alex. And, uh,
because Alex didn't have his id with him,
they didn't sell him a beer. Meanwhile,
we just bought a naked 47 outside and no,
no one asked for id or even our names.
That's funny. It keeps cutting out. Jamie.
Maybe we should switch it over to a
lower stream or something like that.
Try that. Try that. See if that helps.
We'll fix it for you folks, folks. Um,
the, uh, the, the gun issue is a really a,
a creepy one in this country
and it's also in my opinion,
connected to the pharmaceutical issue.
And the reason being is that there's this
massive connection between the things
that people are afraid
of when it comes to guns,
which is school shootings and the in the,
like a massive connection between those
and the use of Ssri and antidepressants.
And there's something like,
I think the latest statistic was it was
more than 90% of all school shooters,
uh, either are on antidepressants
when they do it or are recovering from
antidepressants when they do it.
And that's one of those things
that makes you wonder like,
which came first, the chicken or the
egg, right. Yeah. You know? Yeah,
no, definitely. I'm in like a, I think
when you talk about those mass units,
and actually we shot this and the last
day of, of, um, of shooting was, um,
the aurora shooting less
Dave filming. Oh Wow. Uh,
the gun space was the, the
Aurora shooting. That's
incredible. Yeah. And then,
you know, so it's been in the camp for
awhile, this piece. And then, you know,
when Newtown happened,
you know,
there was some question of whether
we should air the show, uh, the, the,
the guns episode early. But,
um, we decided, you know,
there was enough debate going on at that
point. It just to hold it off. Um, yeah.
And then he used the guide, the
aura, the, um, the new town, um,
sandy hook shooting.
He used a bushmaster,
which we also saw for sale at gun shows.
What is that 10 or 15?
I've thought the Sandy Hook.
I used pistols.
I think that sandy hook guy used
the Ed Bushmaster. Yeah. Hmm.
I just look it up.
I'm pretty sure.
Or the,
the new findings or the sandy hook
shooting was that he actually didn't use
assault weapon pistols.
Hold on.
I'm saying we should know
NBC admitted no assault rifle
used in new town shooting.
Um,
do,
do, do, do, do, do, do, do,
do, do too. Um, for hand guns.
Apparently only handguns
were taking into the school.
Yeah, I think, um, yeah, he had,
it had been said that he had,
oh,
he had an ar 15 assault rifle
that he taken into the school. Um,
and it was in the car that he drove there,
but they've been told by several officials
that he had left it in the car and
then he came in and just
shut everyone pistols.
I remember when the reports
came out hearing about the
bushmaster that he had to
bushmaster. And I remember clearly
having seen it and the gun shows and we,
you know,
we almost bought one.
I mean we're really beach spin.
This is just sort of a technicality here.
But what kind of gun he used, um,
the obviously shot a bunch of people.
That's what's important is it someone
can get this tool and really that's what
it is and inanimate tool and a person
can get it and go do these things.
And these things happen very rarely.
And when they happen,
there's this massive reaction and the
reaction is almost always to try to take
guns away. And that's what gets
like the real nutters. Crazy,
right? I ain't going to
take my cold dead fingers.
Romaco and it's, um, it's,
it's almost like it's one the
strangest debates in our culture
because it's not a gun. It's
killing all these people. It's,
it's a person who's doing something
that is horrific and impossible.
Stop. It's, it's, it's a person
that's doing something. So if,
if, if they didn't have a gun, who
knows what they would do? I mean,
would they try to do it with a car where
they just plow over a bunch of people
in the road? Would they,
would they make a bomb?
The idea is that this tool makes
it easier for them to do it,
but the reality is the gun's
not doing shit on its own.
And the real issue in my mind is always
been a person able to do something like
that.
Like how does that happen and
why is that sort of brushed away?
Everyone just wants to talk about gun
control and then it gets up this debate
and humans are so wacky
that when there's a debate,
there's two sides screaming at each
other and nothing gets done. You know,
you have the Ted Nugent side,
that stockpile and ammo because
they think Obama's to, uh, you know,
turn the whole country into
communist Russia. And then, you know,
you've got the other side that want
the, you know, that say, fuck hunters,
you should just kill hunters. No
one should have a gun, you know,
get your meat from a supermarket. This is
bullshit. We need to, we need to evolve.
You know, there's, there's that,
that argument as well and my opinion,
it's a mental health issue. And
uh, just the fact that guns exist,
like guns are crazy.
The idea that you could just point
at something and make it disappear,
but there's so many guns,
there's so many gun owners and it's so
rare if you look at it statistically that
something like this happens.
If you look at how many human
beings we have in this country,
it's like 300 million and how many
shootings like this happen where someone
indiscriminately just starts
whacking people around them.
It's kind of strange that it's so rare
because there's so many fucking nuts.
Yeah. So many fucking crazy people
in this country. It's almost,
we're like blessed that these things
don't happen on a regular basis. Right.
Well in many ways I think the gun debate
is an easier debate to have if it's the
same with addiction, right? I mean like
addictions, very complicated issue.
Mental health is a very
complicated issue and you know,
it's not as easy as to talk about.
Do you want guns or do you want that
one Collins? And I think you know what,
not to have guns.
And I think what we were trying to show
in an RPA says that like the same laws
that make it easy for anybody to access
guns also makes it easy for people who
you don't want to having
guns and have guns.
And so if you're comfortable with that,
and then there were many states and there
are many people that are comfortable
with that, that that's, that's great. And
uh, if you know, if you're not, if you,
if you fear the damage that had gun can
do, um, in a, in the wrong person's hand,
then you know,
that's also a worthy thing to debate.
I think it's a much easier debate.
I agree with you.
It's much more black and white.
It's about having the right to bear
arm to have arms and what should be the
limits on that. And then, and then
pills, which actually, you know, um,
it's a much more of a gray area debate.
Yeah, it certainly is. Um, and
even if there is gun laws,
I guess you could punish people harder
for selling you an AK 47 and a parking
lot. But the fact that you could
just do it. Yeah, that's a,
the anybody wants to stop background
checks from owning guns is an asshole.
It's really that simple.
Yeah. I mean I think it's,
there is the vast majority of people
just agree on most things and then it's,
you know,
the sort of extremes of both sides that
sort of hindsight to debate and you know,
background checks.
You know,
we go through background checks anytime
we want to buy a car or you know,
like you know, and they ask
for id if you want to write it.
So why not ask for your id or to get the
background check if you want to buy a
dangerous weapon.
I saw the best Twitter post on this.
Somebody wrote this is the
way to solve the gun problems.
Take everybody who has a gun and killed
him. And I was like, Jesus Christ.
See that is talking about missing the
point. That doesn't help the debate.
But it was just one of those things that
like this extreme reaction that people
have to, to the, to the gun issue
when the reality is, and you know,
and I'm not in the Ted Nugent camp,
but the reality is when you look at the
actual numbers of people with guns and
the small amount of times
of these things happen,
it's really not a gun issue.
It's a mental health issue.
But there's the sort of pedestrian
violence that happens every day. Sure.
There's rare mass shootings and stuff
like that, but every day, you know,
either accidentally or on purpose, people
are getting shot with guns and killed.
You know, it's true. And you know,
the thing is, is that, uh, the,
the part that I loved about doing the
piece and was when we started out as we
went to, uh, this, um, shooting range and
we with Po took part in this festival,
um, independent state rifle
match. Yeah. Um, and you know,
there were guys that are very obviously
very pro gun on and like with disagree
with anybody who says that they should
be any limits on gun ownership or
anything like that. But
at same time, you know,
a lot of the guys who we're speaking to,
we're very serious about the safety
that went into to, you know, what,
owning a gun. There's a responsibility
there that if you own something,
just like if you own or drive a car,
there's a responsibility to know how
to drive a car and had, you know, to,
to educate yourself. And so, you
know, the NRA, um, they often,
they offer these pistol classes and
they teach you how to, you know,
on load load and how to do
everything safely. And you know,
I think it's not mandatory for gun owners,
but I think anybody that wants to own a
gun should certainly take a class in how
to handle, handle, handle a weapon
because they're super dangerous. Yeah.
I don't think there's any
debate in that whatsoever.
And I think another issue that needs to
be taken into consideration is how many
people's lives are saved with guns
from bad guys. I mean, how many, um,
how many times have a police in, in, in
justifiable cases shot people. I mean,
when you look at the number of
people that shot in this country,
sometimes it's people that are
protecting their home from a,
a burglar and sometimes
it's a woman trying to prevent a rape. I
mean, all these things are true as well.
So it isn't a black and white issue.
And that's what gets people really weird.
And you know, by the way, if you really,
if you really adamant about gun control
and you've really adamant about stopping
gun violence, pay attention to the
fact that we're involved in wars too.
Crazy ones.
And they're in places that don't make any
sense and people are dying over there.
Just, yeah, a lot of innocent people.
And you know, how about drones,
you know,
there's a lot of other shit going on.
It's not just happening right here.
It's a violence issue.
It's a attachment from humanity
issue. It's, it's a very strange one.
It's one that seems to be lingering in,
uh, in our transition from this, you know,
primal, Alpha male monkey thing that we
used to be to whatever we're becoming.
As we become more and more educated and
more and more aware of the consequences
of our actions and more and more
hopefully enlightened. Where were we?
We're still,
we still have this thing where you could
just press a button and people explode,
you know?
And anybody can get one in the parking
lot after being online in 45 minutes,
which sounds strange. I mean,
people are so God damn strange,
and you really look at it that way. If
you were an objective observer, you know,
from another planet that sent
here to report back on earth, boy,
what a fucking story you would have.
You'd have to sit them down
and you'd have to go, okay,
well this was not what we had hoped for.
And we just say that first.
They're fucking crazy. First
of all, they're all on pills.
They got guns, they're on pills. No
one knows what the fuck they're doing.
It's all bananas.
Yeah.
Journalists are driving into trees or 90
miles an hour, not leaving skid marks.
When you guys saw that,
did you get scared?
Like thinking about the
business that you're in?
We're talking about Michael Hastings who
a a journalists for the rolling stone
magazine and he was involved in exactly
what you're not involved in and he was
involved in singling out individuals and
going after them and he did did it to a
very powerful general and wrote
some piece in rolling stone.
They got the guy fired and repeatedly
told people that people had told them
they're going to kill him.
Then one day his car
going 100 miles an hour,
uh,
in Hollywood,
slammed directly into a pole
or a tree and killed them,
burst into flames, no skid marks
at all. And you know, you think,
well that's a, that's crazy.
Then this guy who was, uh,
involved in security for President Clinton
and Bush said that you can hack into
a car now and that today it's possible
to hack into a modern car and control the
steering, control, the
acceleration and patrol the brakes.
And then it's very possible you could
remote control a car and make someone
accelerate and slam into a tree,
make the car explode. Wow. Yeah.
Uh, so when I'm starting to
go where the story, yeah.
I mean I've heard the just, um, and some
of the conspiracies that's around this,
I don't really know the details,
but um, I will say that he was,
he was a great reporter and
uh, definitely, um, yeah,
big loss for the industry for sure.
That's a good way to play it safe.
No, no, I don't. I really
don't. I applaud you on your,
so basically tell us what you think.
Oh, I don't know. I have no idea.
I think it would be foolish of me with
my zero understanding of the mechanics of
modern automobiles, zero understanding
of the computer equipment that runs them.
I have zero technical knowledge,
Richard Clark. So it was, yeah,
it was a several others as well who
have studied the, the mechanisms behind,
uh, the possibilities of
remote controlling various
things, hacking into them,
you know, um, I don't know on our
own what's true. I have no idea,
but it's scary, scary scenario.
It's very scary. Yeah.
I mean it's trying to have a moving.
We've got just drives it. He's,
he's about to release this crazy story,
tells everyone that the FBI is looking
into them and interviewing all of his
friends and then,
and do a tray boom and the car
explodes and he dies and no story.
It's just kind of slowly
disappear. You know, Kim Cardiac,
she won't get pregnant from some other
dudes and like a couple of months and
Kanye West would be on the
outs and everybody, I forget
about Michael Hastings,
you know, a few people try to talk about
it on the line and uh, other Fox called,
Oh God, he's still talking about Michael
Hanes things. Laennec oh, pulleys.
No, he's talking about the great work
that it definitely did. Yes. Yeah. Um,
but you know,
I think also a thing to
take into consideration and
said we live in an age of
extreme transparency and anybody
who does something that evil,
it's seems like it's almost impossible
to completely cover things up.
And if it's not impossible now I
feel like it will be in a few years.
I feel like any sort of record of
something of that magnitude. Yes.
If this is going to be a way that that's
going to come to light and some sort of
a wikileaks type scenario,
you're an optimist.
I'm an optimist. I May, I would, I would
call a technological optimist. You know,
there's that famous Orson Welles
CHRO that history is a race between,
um, between education
and catastrophe. And uh,
I think if you look at the trends,
education seems to like
kind of always be winning.
And I think part of that it's that
ultimately what's good for the entire race
triumphs over what's good for the few.
And I think even what's good for the few
in terms of a band for the entire race
is bad for the few because I think
there's a thing called Karma.
And I think that's real.
And I think that the effect that you have
on your environment is a very tangible
thing. The way people react to you is
a very physical, real measurable thing.
And that comes from being a piece of shit.
If you're a piece of shit,
you do horrible things. It's very
difficult to feel warm and fuzzy and joy,
love and happiness and have
friends. And I think that, uh,
ultimately technology most likely will
be the tool that balances all that out.
Because I think that with
technology comes as transparency.
And with this transparency,
you get to see the actions of these few,
um, in a different light.
Then we got to see like,
whether it was in the 60s
and the seventies or when
Eisenhower warned of the,
when he left office and he was warning
about the military industrial complex.
That was just of a film that was on
television for one brief moment in a time
where there was no VCRs. So it's like, how
much impact is that even going to have?
Then we'll, whereas now,
many, many years later,
over half a century later,
that film's being played over and over
again on the Internet as an example of
how this is probably an issue that's been
around secretly behind the curtain for
a long time,
but now every day there's some new thing.
Every day there's some
new piece of information.
Every day there's some new story,
you know,
but there it's Edward Snowden
or whether it's, you know,
someone else releasing something else
or it's some people getting arrested for
something that you can't believe is
real. That's, that's almost impossible.
But cover that stuff up these
days. Yeah, no, it's crazy. Yeah.
I like that idea that if she,
people say I'm ridiculous,
you could easily say I'm ridiculous.
First of all,
I'm not qualified to give any
prognostication whatsoever. I'm to camp,
give a prognosis. I mean,
this is just a gut reaction,
but I think that if you look at the way
life used to be a thousand years ago and
the way life is today, you know, try
living in during the inquisition,
try living in the Middle Ages
shows, always hear people, oh we're,
we're living in the most violent time
and it's not actually the least violent
time in history. And we actually
have it pretty good. But yeah,
but I'm a strong believer
in Karma as well.
I think we're dealing with a
time where we're really confused.
There's obviously some bad spots
everywhere and there always have been.
It's very difficult to be a human being
and it's very difficult to develop a
human being, to raise a person.
So to have a baby become an adult,
the processes insane. There's so many
pitfalls and nobody gives you a guidebook.
Nobody knows what the fuck we're doing.
And we're getting information from 7
million or 7 billion rather people a day.
Essentially. We're getting, not all
the information, but anything crazy,
anything fucked up. You know, Nan born
with 10 penis is there he is, you know,
like that'll get through.
Yeah.
That gets through everything crazy gets
through and it's almost like we weren't,
we were designed for that were designed
for what's happening in the tribe.
Who are those guys with swords
coming over the hill. Hey,
we gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
You know,
that's what we're sort of designed for.
We're dealing with the same genetics
essentially that people had 10,000 years
ago and there was no communication
back then. There was nothing.
And now it's on your phone.
I was at a restaurant the other day
with a buddy of mine and I'm like,
I'm a fucking junkie.
I can't put this goddamn phone down.
I have to keep checking the stupid
phone. Um, so I such an asshole,
like I can't see what's going on
on Twitter. You know, it's so bad,
but it's this,
what's happening is I keep getting
information and I'll go and I'll see
something and Ooh,
and maybe I'll see nothing and then
I'll look more and they'll see nothing.
I'll look more than, Ooh, a
new post by someone I follow.
Something crazy is happening,
especially when it's a married couple
and we were wearing the same sort of
business and we're, you know,
always when it journalists over all,
he's looking for information.
But I find that where it's almost
like a ping pong ball four as well.
I'm looking at the phone and he's really
mad at me cause we're having dinner and
I'm looking at the phone and then I put
it down and then he's looking at the
front,
keep the romance alive and
she's checking her phone.
I was at a restaurant the other day and
I watched four people and none of them
talked and they all stay on their phone
the entire time they're sitting there
eating together.
Yeah. But then you look at it
and be like, oh, at least people.
And then five minutes later you're the
one checking your phone and then we're
looking to do so at the same
thing. So it's like, yeah,
we are junkies really are.
I interviewed Ray Kurzweil
for, uh, my, I have a new show
is coming out on by thank you.
And one of the episodes were
talking about the, the convergence,
the human to machine convergence and then
the idea that one day we will be some
sort of a combination of
people and technology and he
was essentially making the
argument that it's already happened and
that it's just we were slowly accepting
it,
but that technology is in pacemakers and
in hearing aids and we are so attached
to our phones that it could be argued
that if you have a certain number of
people that constantly
carry phones with them,
their argument could be that you're
already a part of that. Like what?
You just haven't figured out
a way to put it in your body.
So the way before they had hearing aids,
those dudes used to carry those horns.
They bought lean forward.
You remember those?
Like you'd see them in the old like three
stooges movies and shit and he's like
a giant Buffalo Horn. What?
I would get close to you.
Well, not Google glass and now you don't
even have to hold anything. Have you,
have you played with
Diana? I haven't. Have you?
Yes. Yeah, I got a chance. I have a friend
who works at Google and she let me, uh,
that's one of those things,
yeah. That the, these to look
like that would help you.
Um, he, she let me play with it. It's,
it's a very, very interesting, and it,
it, it feels to me like,
uh, a step like, like, Ooh,
I'm holding onto a model t
right here. Like, this is,
this is what's one day going
to be a Tesla? You know,
one day it's going to be a contact lens
and we're all going to have one or it'll
be some sort of an implant.
So describe it to me. Well,
it's sort of crude because, uh,
sorry, Google, but right now, uh,
it has to be tethered to a phone. Um,
and this is, uh, I played with, uh,
it's not ready for prime time
prototype. It's a prototype and, uh,
a Google fallen at that and,
um, you do things to it.
Like you can ask for. Um, one of
the things I thought it was cool.
It was like you could
Google like a ray Kurzweil,
you know, Google Ray Kurzweil and, and
all of a sudden it shows you like a,
a page like right out of Google on Ray
Kurzweil and you can like see like Google
Gray Kurzweil video and it shows you all
these video options and then you could
play them off of youtube,
but it's like projected somewhere.
Are you looking at the
glass? Yes, there it is.
That's me with one of those things that
you can see it over there to miss this
TV in front of you actually at
this one. No worries. Um, yeah. Um,
you see it sort of floating in space,
but nobody can see it.
Like if I have it on and I'm talking
to you, you can't see what I'm saying.
I see it. But you can't see it. And it's
one of those things where if you like,
look over here, you don't see it, but
you look here, you see it Israeli trippy.
It's strange.
But the strangest aspect is that I felt
like I was holding onto something that
was going to be something
way greater someday.
And this is just the first steps of this
weird sort of a transformation and to
the uh, the, the symbiotic. So
while right, it's freaky not,
not sure if I'm looking forward
to it and I have to say,
I feel like I am cause I feel like,
um,
I enjoy so many aspects
of technology already.
I think people are afraid for the most,
we're afraid of a loss of privacy.
But if we could get people
to stop being assholes,
if everybody was like freely cool,
would you care if everybody looked
at your pictures and got into email?
We know that everybody is, that people
are looking at everything we do,
but our issue is not with
people looking at our stuff.
Our issues are with assholes looking
at our stuff or people using our
information against us.
That's what we're really concerned with.
And I wonder if you could
extrapolate the sort of the, this,
this,
this thing that we're going through with
technology where this is massive curve
and it's spinning and spinning faster
and faster until you're this exponential
growth.
If it was possible to somehow another
encouraged that and human behavior as well
as with technology.
If technology could be used by in,
in, in aiding in this sort of like
connection with people in aiding,
in emphasizing empathy and emphasizing
a comradery and friendship and love,
if that could be like seen as like a more
worthwhile ethic and more worthwhile,
like a state of
consciousness and behavior.
It sounds like very hippie now you're
really optimistic. I think it's possible.
I really do think that
there's repercussions that
people experience now when
they do something terrible to someone on
like on the Internet where there's this
flood of Red Rock, we'll go after
them now that no one ever had before.
You know, like did you ever see there
was a video where anonymous, uh,
released this video of this girl who was
throwing puppies into a river and then
they went after, exposed her and
chase her and it was really horrific.
But this, this, this, the,
the people swarmed on this evil behavior.
They saw that someone was doing something
terrible and they went after it.
And this one example is also
the example of the, uh, the,
what happened in Ohio with a,
the rapes were they were,
they were trying to cover it up and that
was also exposed by hackers and then
the massive amount of negative attention
that was given on those people.
And it's like in time,
would that not slowly sort
of like cure people of this,
this sort of behavior
or if not cure people,
make it far less likely to happen?
Yeah.
The golden rule becomes a,
because people know what the fuck's going
on and they're not going to tolerate
it. If everyone knows it's
something like that happened.
Someone did a horrible thing,
wouldn't that lessen the
occurrences of these things?
If there were repercussions,
the masses had access.
The problem is of course,
that we don't think we don't think
of that loss of privacy in that way.
We think of a loss of
privacy and big brother.
We think of like the NSA's is listening
to all your phone calls and copying all
your emails and you know, it sounds very,
are well in and dangerous and scary,
you know, and that this is a, an
erosion of privacy, but it's also,
it seems inevitable.
It seems inevitable.
And if it's not inevitable in the
sense that the government gets it,
I think they just going to get,
they might get ahold of it first,
but it seems like it's,
everybody's going to get it right.
Like it's just,
that's where it's going.
It's all moving to this area of
no boundaries. It's very weird.
But if you look at how life has
changed since the Internet, you know,
and when did we get it? Like
90 Ish, 94 ish when it really
took hold. I got an AOL,
I think it was in 94 I was on
your side adopter. Yeah. Well, uh,
I owe it to my friend Robbie. Robbie
was a computer major. Robbie Printz,
what's up dude?
He was a computer major in college and
then became a standup comedian and was
telling me like, oh, it's a great way to
write your jokes. I can have a fucking,
I didn't know how to type it all out,
but I remember getting
online the first day, uh,
on AOL and they have like all
these categories you can look into.
And I was fascinated.
I was like,
this is the craziest thing I've ever
seen in my life. If you have a question,
and it was so rudimentary and
crewed with a 14, four baud modem,
but extrapolate that from 1994 take,
take 1994 and go and look at how we are
now in 2013 I would have never guessed,
first of all,
I'd never guessed that I'd be sitting
in some room talking to some people who
made a documentary that I said.
And the only way we communicated
until today was strictly through this
electronic medium. No publicists,
no nothing, no one hooking this up.
And no, like no formal
process. And then now,
no producers, no network,
no nothing, no filtration,
no censorship instantaneously broadcast.
And My,
my Ustream page as right now
it's 14 million views. Yeah.
So it's, it's reaches a lot
of people. It's not like,
it's not like a couple of Weirdos are
checking it out and then it goes on iTunes
and it at least a half a million.
We'll download each
individual episode from the,
either that or stitcher
or just the raw MP3.
Like this is a crazy shift in the way
things were done just 20 years from now.
And then you think about Facebook,
you think about Twitter,
you can take a picture of something,
you put it online and then this guy
retweets it and that guy retweets it.
And if it's something, especially if
it's something big or a story big,
it could get retweeted by millions.
And then before you know it,
it becomes a new story.
it becomes something that the whole
country knows about and it's almost
instantaneous.
I look at that and I say,
how is it possible that that's not
going to continue to go in that same
direction and I really do think
it's going to be beneficial.
I think there's going to be pitfalls
for sure as we sort of figure out are
weighed and how to navigate this
new world that we live in. You know?
Pardon the phrase, but I ultimately
think that it's going to be beneficial.
I am
sold.
I think it's going to no dairy
technology here. No, I am too.
It's just that it's going to make our
romantic dinners even harder. Yeah,
because you'd be like,
are you looking at me?
Are you looking at your Google
contact lens? Right, right. Exactly.
You son of a bitch, look into my,
I'm not sure what we'll have to,
the thing is about these things.
They seem to want to operate
on voice recognition.
It seems to be that's what the trend
is where these things that'd be very
difficult to hide. Yeah. You know,
you can't say, oh listen honey,
I totally did Google, blah, blah, blah. I
totally agree with you. Google new shoes.
I don't know, I guess, I mean,
it'd be nice if we all took our
Google contact lenses off as we, uh,
entered in exactly. Men To town.
Yeah. It's, I guess it's, it's,
it's just an inevitability of the world
we live in and we just have to accept
the fact that the times they
are changing for the better.
Hopefully I think maybe I'm wrong.
I'm fucking wrong. Don't listen to me.
What are some of the
discussions you guys cover?
Uh, the third episode is sex
trafficking actually. Oh,
that was really interesting one.
Yes. So, um, it is, you know,
you think about tex trafficking,
you think of foreign women being
drawn into the United States. Well,
it's 10 times more likely that an
American is being trafficked than it is a
foreigner in another country right here
in American here in the United States.
Yes. And American here in the US.
So we basically went undercover.
I went undercover as a prostitute trying
to get a job at a massage parlor in
Houston.
And I mean within five minutes I was
approached by this guy who tried to get me
to be a prostitute for him. He wanted
to be, do you want it to be my pimp?
And uh,
meanwhile Darren was filming all of
this from across the street in the car.
Oh my God.
I know you're not freaking out.
Well you must be freaking out a little
bit. He was. And because, you know,
technology
has evolved so much, but we, we don't,
we didn't have all the technology
we it with us at the time.
We just had our iPhone,
I had my iPhone on mute but
on speakerphone so he could
hear what was happening.
And then I had the little glasses,
secret filming glasses and,
but the only way he could hear me was
through my speaker phone, iPhone. And um,
the whole time I was holding the
iPhone while talking to this guy.
So it looked really strange cause I was
trying to get Darren to hear what was
happening and the guys saying, you
know, you're, where are you from?
You look like you're from Sweden, don't
you? You, you can get a lot of clients.
I can make you thousands of dollars
every night and you look so clean,
which is a compliment that
I've never gotten before.
You look really clean when you wonder why
you're a clean, clean girl. Meanwhile,
and he kept on insisting for me to go
into the car with him and Darren across
the street couldn't see where I was at
and thought that I had gotten into the
car with him and was sort of cursing
communion saying, is she crazy?
What is she doing?
And uh,
and then I hadn't gotten into
the car and he kept on saying,
why don't you come into the
car with me? And, uh, I just,
Dave excuses that I didn't
feel very comfortable yet, but,
but I was really looking forward to
working with him because I wanted to know
more information about how this,
these whole rings,
prostitution rings work here in the United
States. And it's really, really sad.
You know, it's these t many
times teenage girls who you know,
are the shopping mall and they were
approached by this guy who says,
you're beautiful. You're the most
beautiful girl I've ever seen.
I'll give you everything you need in
the world. Come with me, travel with me.
You know, sometimes these girls are, for
whatever reason, they're, they, they're,
they don't have good
relationships with their parents,
where they come from a
bad background and they,
they accept and they go travel
around America with these guys.
And very soon after they
become, um, you know,
their sex slaves and they're
sold out for $200 a night.
It's very, very sad. Somehow know the,
keep them from escaping. They
keep them from escaping. Yes.
First by just persuasion,
persuasion and,
and being,
beating them by violence.
Branded with like tattoos or
their pimps and stuff. Yeah.
We interviewed one girl that had a dragon
tattoo with the main panther, sorry,
your Panther Tattoo.
The name of her pimp and the back and
all the girls that were in her ring all
have the same tattoo. And
you know, sometimes they are
scared to go back home. Uh,
some, some of the girls get hooked
on drugs. The pimps get them hooked,
hooked on drugs. And, uh,
and a few of the girls that we interviewed
said they went to the police and told
the police,
but the police didn't believe them
and they just arrested them for being
prostitutes.
So they spend a night in jail and they
kept on saying they had a pimp and the
police did nothing about it.
And as soon as they were released,
the pimp was outside of the jail
waiting for them to come out,
put them right back to work,
to work. Yeah. I mean, they're,
they're worth a lot of
money, you know, shepherds,
it is. It's, it was, yeah, it was, it is.
It really is sad. And it was really
interesting. One of the, the operations,
he sort of undercover operations
we did within a Charlotte, which is
a big place for, for these,
uh, for sex trafficking. Um,
because there are all these interstates,
this is North Carolina,
all these interstates
that meet there. And, uh,
so we went out with this religious group
because of religious groups are out
there doing a lot of outreach for sex
trafficking. And we went out do this,
this religious group that goes
out every night or many weeks,
many nights a week to look for
women to try to recruit them,
take them out of these rings
out of prostitution essentially.
And it was me and this other woman who
works in this organization and we went
out with, again with a secret camera
Garren again, filming from the car.
And as we saw girl who
seemed to be sort of lost,
you had just gotten out of the car,
her jeans were ripped and
we called her and, uh,
start us, are you okay? And she said,
no, I'm not okay. A guy just, you know,
just beat me and I'm not feeling well.
And as we're talking to this girl,
suddenly it's as if we had disrupted
some sort of crazy sex trafficking echo
system and all these pimps come out
of the woodworks, out of the bushes,
literally in the middle of Charlotte and
the main prostitution street and come
out and start circling us.
And they don't know where watching because
Darren's in the car watching them and
start seeing these two pimps sort
of circling us to find out what we,
why we were talking to their girl.
And uh,
and that's when they came out and started
calling us and then we left. But it's,
it's really interesting and it's
happening all around the United States.
Wow.
It's so disturbing or no.
Does that happen in countries
where there's prostitution?
Where's legalized prostitution?
That's a very good question.
I don't know.
I don't, I don't, I, I,
I know just from out of itself, my
head out, I wouldn't think, you know,
obviously one of the big things,
the reason why these rings exist,
it's because it's illegal to be
prostitutes. So the s the prostitutes,
you feel safer.
Um,
if they want to sell themselves and feel
safer having somebody who looks after
them and who essentially at the end
of the day takes away all their money.
So this is what we heard again and again,
it's so,
it's sort of the same issue that exists
in the drug world where if you make
things illegal,
then you sort of create this atmosphere
where only the outlaws profit.
And I know that in Amsterdam where
drugs are pretty much legal or at least
tolerated as far as, uh,
marijuana and many drugs,
they have like a very low rate of
addiction and very low rate of AIDS.
They legalize prostitution.
I would wonder how much of a,
how much of this tour type
of thing of sex slavery is,
is mitigated by that.
Most places in Nevada rivalry
where it's where it's legal.
And I think that's the argument that a
lot of the brothel owners make is that we
can make it safe. We can make
it, you know, um, you know,
the girls that tested girls, um, are
there under their own volition and, um,
you know,
they,
they get to keep their money as
opposed to at the money taken away. Um,
we visited some of these brothels and
I was actually really different. Yeah.
Different show, but, but
uh, you know, they, they,
they get tested for aids on a weekly
basis for all sorts of sexual transmitted
disease on a weekly basis. And
you know, the girls feel safe.
At least they're in the brothel
and they're not out in the streets.
Yeah. I would look. And then
it's another one of those things.
It's like a personal freedom issue.
Almost like that should a woman,
if she's crazy and she loves sucks,
should she be allowed to be a prostitute?
I wouldn't want my daughter or my age,
my friend's daughter or my friend.
I wouldn't want anybody
that I know doing that.
I wouldn't want anyone that
I know being a prostitute.
But I also wouldn't want anybody I know.
Being a hired killer,
I wouldn't want anybody I know, uh,
working on an oil field when it blows up,
it is a lot of things I
wouldn't want my friends to do.
But do I think that they should
be allowed to be a prostitute?
Why is it that sex is something that
everybody wants but you can't sell it? No.
Why is that? I mean, I'm
says, yeah, who says,
yeah, we've met. I mean, we've met women
on all sides of this issue and you know,
women that are high paid call girls and
stuff like that, very much. He does it,
you know, and empower him an
issue. And uh, but you know,
the vast majority I think of girls
out there, it'd be an exploited. Um,
I guess it will. And, um, I think that
that's the issue and it is because, uh,
because it's illegal.
Yeah. Me, it's, again,
it goes down to that same
issue of human nature. We're,
we're such a strange animal. And when
you tell us that something is wrong,
that we can't do it, then it becomes this
weird itch that people want to scratch.
You know? And I, I wonder how many
people actually, I wonder if that study,
how many people actually go to prostitutes
because it's illegal as opposed to
legal, prostitutes and countries where
it's tolerated. I wonder if they have, uh,
you know,
less people side by side study between
double blind placebo prostitutes study.
Exactly. Can we do it? Can
we get funding for that?
Well, it, it's, it's so, uh,
you know, it's, it's, it's so,
it seems like a pattern, you know,
that exists. Things are illegal.
People want to do them, bad people sell
them to the people that want to do them.
Then you have crime. Yeah. Right.
Yeah. And then we go, there we go.
Do a show about him off.
Um,
is there anything that you guys
did during this new show that,
that really shocked too?
Is there anything that like it really
stands out or something that you'd never
expected?
Um, I mean I thought it was the,
the, the, the, the pimp moment was,
it was a shocking one. I've never seen
a uh, uh, a pimp like sort of uses game,
uh, to try to pick someone up before I've
heard, I've heard about it, you know,
secondhand stories, but to actually see,
and especially since it was my wife,
but that was, that was real
interesting how, how they,
they sorta talk about
and they try to sell it.
I was,
I was really nervous going in,
not only because I was filming under
cover and that is always nerve racking,
but also because I was
trying to apply for a job
just to show you sort of what,
what this is like,
what these with this sex
trafficking underworld is like, uh,
not that I was going to work as
a prostitute, but just to do,
to be able to get into
these massage parlors and,
and see how easy it is to get a job.
And I was nervous that they were
going to turn me down and say,
I'm sorry you were to roll.
Ah, you know, as a woman,
that's the first thing.
So when this guy approaches me and starts
a saying that I looked very clean, um,
and you always go, hey, I came back and
passed. Uh, yeah, I came back to the car.
The first thing I told Daren, it's
like I still have, I still got it.
That's hilarious. Um, what are
the subjects were covered? I mean,
how many episodes you guys do?
It's six episodes. Six episodes.
We covered animal rights activism.
Um, oh, did you count couple,
the Animal Liberation Organization animal?
Yeah,
no, we, we, we, we didn't really
delve into that too much. What we,
what we were looking into was, um, the,
the guys that go on the cover and to like
factory farms and film like the abuse
of animals on factory farms and then
they turn it into campaigns to, uh,
try to get people to stop eating meat or
to sort of improve conditions for, um,
for factory farm animals
and stuff like that. So, um,
there's, yeah, the, you know,
this sort of whole,
um,
very successful campaign by animal rights
groups in the last decade or so that
I've used it on the cover of camera.
And so we figured,
since we're doing a show
about on the cover of filming,
you know, like, what's a,
let's see if we can,
you know,
hook up with these guys and see
what their world is like. So we,
we hooked up with this one guy who's
been doing it for like 10 years and he's,
he remains anonymous. Um, it goes by,
you know, a fake name in the shell, but,
uh, his whole life has just
been penetrating these farms
and capturing, uh, yeah.
Pictures of abuse on,
on film and stuff.
And this is a guy who's obviously, he's
Vegan, he's completely against, uh,
the eating, uh, consumption
of animal meat. And he still,
every day he goes to work when he goes
under cover and he has to kill these
animals. Um, just to be able to record
what's happens inside these factory farms.
And then there's,
the legislation is being passed right
now in several states to start to try to
stop, to prohibit what these guys are
doing. My filming under cover. So, yeah.
Yeah, I've seen that. Yeah.
And how's, how's that flying?
How are they allowing people to do that?
Because everyone is outraged when
they see those videos. Even the media,
they watch those videos of people.
Like I saw one of this, uh,
abuse that was going on when these cows,
where this guy was like hitting a cow
with a crowbar. There's so horrific.
And again, another thing that's
being exposed by technology. Yeah.
I believe that that video, yeah, video
could have very well come from
the guy that we feature. Um,
he's sort of the main one of the,
the biggest um,
undercover animal rights
activists altruists voice
and blur out his face or his
voice. But we definitely heard his, he was
in disguise actually, but he's, he has,
he's had,
I don't know how many name changes
throughout his life and he's been doing,
it's really hard course and he's sort of,
if you ever want to do
any undercover is filming,
this is the guy you need to talk to.
And he actually gave me some training
because a lot of all of this show is about
undercover filming. He gave me
training into filming undercover.
He sent me out into a parking lot and
tell me that first I had to go to that
woman over there.
She's a perfect stranger and you have
to ask are you have to get information
from her.
I want to know where she lived before she
lived here and I had to go and do that
and I passed that really easily.
But then the second test that he made me
do was I had to go out there and make a
woman sort of run away from
me because she was scared.
And I'm not very good at that. I'm good
at getting information from people,
but I can't,
it's not in my nature to be mean
or too scary or intimidating and a,
so I went to a starking lot
and I just started acting wild,
crazy and not really scary.
Just crazy. Like where is water?
Where can I find some water?
People were just staring at me with this
crazy woman probably thinking that was
on bath salts or something.
Why were,
why were they trying to get you
to do all these different big,
so this is part of the training is that
you have to be able to make people feel
either very comfortable with you, so
they give you information that you need,
that you want to get for your,
for your undercover filming
or very uncomfortable with
you so that you feel the
need to either leave so you can fill more
or intimidating to a point intimidated
to the point that you will release any
information you give without actually
resorting to violence,
obviously. So it was really,
it was really an interesting little
practice that we had with them.
Wow.
And how long has this guy been doing this?
10 years. Yeah. Trains other
people. He's the major,
the main trainer of undercover filming
for animal rights activists in the United
States.
It's an incredible guy.
It seems to me that that's another
one of those things where it sort of a
diffusion of responsibility thing when
there's so many people that want meet so
many people that want, you know, food.
And if he could figure out how it's
stuff them into smaller packages,
he can extract more ones in
Zeros. Yeah, definitely correct.
And I mean that's just it. You know, these
guys that do the undercover, you know,
filming, they, they
obviously have an agenda,
which is they want people to
become Vegan, but they, they're,
they're very sympathetic to
the workers who, you know,
sort of toil under conditions that
can be at times be pretty stressful.
And that's what sort of causes
them to lash out many times. Um,
and then the sort of agriculture
industry obviously just sees this as a,
you know, a pretty big threat. You know,
these guys coming in and filming on
the cover and their farms and you know,
their, their argument is that,
you know, they're capturing,
capturing these anomalies. You know,
this doesn't happen every day. Um,
and they're using it to sort
of amplify their issue. Right.
What is his take on this though?
His take is not that. It's not,
it's not an anomaly at all.
No,
not, he says that in every single farm
he's ever entered and he's ever filmed
undercover. He is witnessed
animal abuse. Yeah.
Wow.
That was a stake.
Does he go to these organic free
range places he ever tried to like,
you know, the, the biggest sort of target
for them with a bigger factory farm?
Boy, would it freak people out though if
you could go to the grass fed free range
farm and wash them abusing
cows to and be like, oh shit.
Because that's what everybody wants to
pretend I don't have any murder on my
hands.
Why my meat is grass fed and they smile
right before they cut their throats.
Right.
We actually went to
a slaughterhouse and now actually that
was probably a, that was possible. Yeah.
Asked before.
It would have been one of the most,
probably the most surprising thing we
did is we went through a slaughter house,
but it was that, uh,
it was that, you know,
as humane ranch or certified
humane ranch. And it was, you know,
like we start the whole process. We saw
them tagging a baby calf, like baby calf.
That was just bond with born within
the night, the last 24 hours. Uh,
Mariana got to like tie the
cashier and then, you know,
we saw the other night of the
process where, you know, uh,
what is it 18 months later
or something like that,
that they're slaughtered and they'd let
us onto the float of slaughter house and
they said, you know, that we have an
open door policy because, you know,
we want to be sort of transparent
as possible and you know,
about how this food is raised and
how it's slaughtered. And, um,
you know, if, you know,
I've been eating meat all my life and
I've never once seen a cow slaughtered.
And I thought it was a really
eye opening experience, you know,
to be able to sort of consume thousands
and thousands of meals and, and you know,
not know exactly where
you're so disconnected from
where our food comes from,
just as you know, how do they
kill the cow? So they use a,
what they call a knocker
and they, um, basically, um,
it's a like no country for old men.
Yes, exactly. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
And it's sort of stuns the cow. It, you
know, it doesn't kill them right away, uh,
but it definitely sort of paralyzes them
for a moment and puts them into a deep
unconscious state. Um, and did I hang
up that upside down and they slept it,
throw it in, they cut the, you know,
the auto reason and they never wake up
from that. You don't lead them to that.
So it's almost instant. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And it seems fairly humane. Yeah.
It's not how it happens at every
farm though. You know, again,
this is a humane farm.
What's the least humane way they
do it? Well, Osha is really bad,
or I have no idea. Pretty sure kosher.
They just cut their neck. I think kosher,
that's,
there's a process that has to be
followed and I'm one of the parts of the
process and involves cutting
the neck. Yeah. I think they,
I don't think you're allowed to
use that stun thing. It's kosher.
Yeah. There are some things that are
called standard farming, uh, procedures.
I think it is,
right.
Standard standing far standard farming
procedures and a of legal common farming
practices. A perfectly
legal but, but you know,
so violent to see and we watched tons
of videos of this that will filmed
undercover. But the debate, the
DP DV, King of, uh, of chickens,
they don't poke each other because
it gets so close to each other.
Like the cutting of the tales of the pigs,
all that is just hard to see.
The taking away of the,
the baby pigs from their mom mother is um,
you know,
when you can see them caged in
these little tiny compartments.
All that is, you know, again, common
farming practices, but very hard to see.
And obviously there's a lot of interest
there for us to be disconnected for our
food and not see what happens. And
I'm not a vegetarian at all. Um,
I still eat meat, but it was definitely
a very interesting piece to be a part of.
And, and to, to find out more
about how that all works.
I'm not a vegetarian, I'm not
a vegetarian either. But I,
I certainly am not a fan of human cruelty.
And I think that's the real issue.
It's not whether these animals
do not live forever. And uh,
the reality is that there,
there's quite a few realities
when it comes to being a Vegan.
One of them is if you do decide that no
one's going to eat meat anymore and we
make a law and the whole world
has to let all the animals go, um,
they're going to keep fucking and they're
going to keep making baby animals and
then he got a real problem because
what are you going to do then?
Are you going to castrate the males?
Are you going to sterilize them in some
way or are you going to reintroduce
predators into the environment that you're
going to have to do something to keep
the population down?
And I dunno how you plan on doing that,
but how are you going to do
that and not put into jeopardy?
Human beings is a reason why we
rose to the top of the food chain.
And one of the reasons why is because
we can control our environment from
predators.
We can box up a city,
make it nice and tall and
keep out the mountain lions.
And we know how to do that. There's never
been a mountain lion in New York City.
Santa Monica recently. See
that one every time I run. And
I saw one very recently in Santa Barbara,
I was driving through Monosito,
you know where Monosito isn't really
beautiful neighborhood and this fucking
thing ran across the road. And my wife
initially said Coyote, she goes, look,
it's a coyote.
And I thought it was a coyote.
Well you know we saw in our headlights
and then I saw the tail and it's tail and
I noticed that its body was like kind of
bouncy whereas coyotes are really stiff
and you know they have that sort of
stiff twitchy leg movement and sort of a
thing. Oh Shit. Some outline and I'm like
in Santa Barbara, oh man, this is crazy.
It's like this is a really urban place.
There's a guy,
some guy had national geographic right
now doing a story on like urban wildlife.
And he recently released the pitcher
of um, uh, I think it was a bobcat.
I don't think it was a mountain lion,
but it was a bobcat and it's like caught
by one of those trigger cams and it's
like at night.
And the whole background of downtown La
is it basically taken by the observatory
where either lots of animals
and the children running around.
But the Griffith Observatory is
hardly La. It's pretty rural. Yeah.
That's a small area that's rural,
but they have coyotes biting people there.
Like some homeless person went to sleep
there and woke up because it got bit by
a coyote. Coyote came around and tested
them just to see if they could eat. Yeah.
Is that good? Well the guy might
have been really fucked up, you know,
who knows how drunk or high or messed
up because he's in our backyard
constantly. Oh yeah.
Watch a caddie, Nassau,
all they are they still your car? Very
few people in la let their cats out. Well,
cause I mean you see all the missing
signs in the neighborhoods or anything.
It's like, sorry. You
know what happens. Yeah.
I live in a really rural
place and there's a,
there was a mountain lion siting in my
neighborhood about a year ago and coyotes
are there every day,
sea hawks and we saw cro in our yard
and all these other crows were squawking
and we're trying to figure out
what's going on in the crow was a,
there's something wrong with it.
Obviously it was like kind of hobbling
and hopping around in this branch,
but he couldn't fly away. So we went
inside and then we came out like,
I don't know,
a couple hours later and there was
just feathers and guts everywhere.
All it had to do was people had to get
away for a little bit and then some
Predator came swooping in. It was
probably a raptor. Okay. Or you know,
some sort of, yeah. Hawk hawks are
everywhere around where I live, man,
they're big too,
man.
A big creepy murderers just fly
flying murders from the sky,
swooped in and Jack this crow. I mean,
they don't eat berries. Original drones.
Yeah,
hawks hawks don't steal tomatoes.
They didn't have jack moving things and
anything sick. I'll take care of this.
I got it. They like the cleanup crew
for the wounded animals. So, you know,
animals eat other animals and it's
another problem I would say is that okay?
Is it much more humane
for a deer to get eaten?
Slowly buy a pack of wolves. There needs
to get shot by a hunter. You know, it, it,
I don't like the idea of veganism,
but I don't like the idea
of animal cruelty either.
They think that's what most people lands.
Right. I've been so, um, but you know,
like the, the animal rights
groups that, you know, they,
they I think have done an effective job
of sort of getting people like us who
eat meat and uh, thinking about it.
Yeah. Thinking about it. Yes. You know,
it is hard to watch people beating a
cow or something like that and it should
never exist. And it's, again, it goes
back to like the same thing. It's,
it's a human issue. It's about
humanity. It's about what,
what is causing a person to do something
like that? Well, it's a mental illness.
It's a sickness hitting a cow with
a crow bar. What is happening?
How is that possible? Yeah, I
couldn't do it. You couldn't do it.
Why is it happening?
Yeah, so I a, when we interviewed the
woman who runs this humane farm, I,
one of the questions I had
was why do you treat that?
Because they really put a lot of effort
into treating these cows well while
they're alive. Why? Why do you put such
emphasis and treating well the cows,
if you know they're going
to die, if you, you know,
the farm's going to kill them anyway.
And she said exactly because we are
going to kill them and use them for meat.
They're going to be our food.
Exactly. Because of that we, it is,
it is mandatory for us to treat them well.
And I really like that philosophy.
I think that's a beautiful philosophy.
I watched a,
an episode of Anthony Bourdain's
old show, no reservations. And the,
one of the things, it was about
this place in New York that is, um,
they are not just a restaurant there,
a restaurant and they have their own
butcher shop and they also have their own
farm. So they grow all of their food.
I guess it was Maine. They, yes. Okay.
I'm confusing two different things.
One of them was a,
a butcher shop that's also a farm and
they grow their own food and they kill
their own animals and then sell the meat.
So you know, you're getting it humanely.
And the other one was a
farm in Maine where they,
they locally source everything from
their own farm, all their food, all,
all the vegetables,
all the animals.
And they were showing all the different
pigs they raise and they're petting the
pigs and you know, talking about the
different parts that are going to be,
and it's Kinda weird because you're like,
well that's your pet in that thing and
they're going to kill it. But is it,
is it better that way?
Yeah, it's better that way.
It'd be nice to him until he decided
to be really mean, you know? Yeah.
I mean,
it's probably one of those things that
as we developed synthetic meat, oh man.
Yeah, we're probably going to move
away. Well, they're really close.
Then some guy in like London
or England has done it Rad.
He's figured out how to do it.
He's made the first hamburger or
something like that. I don't know.
I don't know where they have,
but I do know that they're,
they're capable of doing things now where
they can reproduce cells and they can
reproduce certain types
of tissue. Like, um,
Kurzweil was telling me about this
woman who had something wrong with her
esophagus.
So they built an Esophagus,
a out of biodegradable material,
used skin cell stem cells,
and you use the biodegradable
material as a scaffolding.
Stem cells built a brand new
esophagus and they operate on her,
installed the new one, and now she's
fine, you know? And that's like,
they're making parts for humans.
So that just seems to make sense that
they're going to make meat. Like,
and I don't know how to feel about that.
Yeah.
Maybe vegans will eat like a fake stick.
Yeah. Maybe they're down with that. Yeah.
It really is delicious and Karma free.
Nice Karma free cheeseburger.
That'd be awesome. Yeah. I think
that's inevitable. It's common. I mean,
they're going to there you're
talking about doing it with humans.
They're talking about developing
parts that are completely artificial,
completely artificial cells that
interact with yourselves with no immune
response.
There are,
they're talking about these things
being an inevitability of the future.
That's not science fiction fact. It's
all based on proven research and, and uh,
there's proof of concepts already
available and it just seems to make sense.
They're going to have a fake chicken,
a fake headless chicken running
around just waiting for you to eat it.
Breasts and legs doesn't
know what's going on.
That literally has no brain.
It's not that they're stupid.
They have zero brains because every
chicken stupid. But this would be like,
there's nothing going on. You don't
have to worry at all it. Right.
Pick it up and kill it. You
know what I mean? Killing it.
I know a lot of other lists. It's like
all the million things that need to do.
We need, yeah, we've actually
had to kill a chicken.
But in Colombia that was, it's,
it's not a pretty process taking,
taking the feathers off the chicken.
And it seems to be the, the, the,
the real thing about killing an animal
and eating an animal is the fact that
this, it's not just that it's alive
because vegetables are alive as well.
It's the fact that it's alive
and it can move and feel pain.
But if you could take away the whole
field pain part and they can't think and
just headless chickens
like you gotta you know,
you have some new sort of a way to
make the heartbeat without a brain just
really fucking stupid headless checkins
he can still wouldn't go for it cause
they don't eat eggs.
And uh,
I have chickens and the chickens lay an
egg every day and you can eat the eggs
and no one gets hurt. But the deacons
are still not down with that? No,
they're not.
But that's how far removed we are from
the farm is that I only found out that
chickens lay an egg a day like two years
ago. Yeah, it's true. I had no idea.
Oh,
I only found out that a an
egg doesn't become a chicken.
I thought that an egg
became a chicken and the,
oh you eat them before it happens.
But no,
it's a hen lays an egg whether
the roosters involved or not.
But if the roosters in the house then
the chicken can get pregnant and then the
egg can become a check. But if there's
no rooster, I didn't know that. See,
most people don't know that isn't it?
It's amazing how removed we are
from the whole process of food.
So there's no life there. No Life at all.
Zero, zero life, zero thread of life.
Impossible to make life.
And in fact if you don't eat the egg
then the chickens will probably eat their
own eggs and go crazy and
I'll come fucking cannibals
or something. I don't know.
And they do eat their own eggs.
If you don't leave them in
too long for vegans though,
the problem is not that they are eating
because they would be life in Yag.
It's because you're eating an egg that
comes from a chicken that is probably
being abused in order to
produce these days. Sure. I
think the thinking behind it,
but you could have it the way I have
it where my, my chickens live on a,
on a full day of a full acre lawn and
they go inside the chicken coop at night,
which is huge and it's,
we set it up like,
cause we wanted to make it as nice as
possible. Super humane, really big place.
Like the chicken coop itself is bigger
than this studio where I have 14 chickens
and they just go in whenever they want
at night and we shut the door and lock it
down. So you get 14 eggs a
day. What do you do with them?
I eat them all 14 delicious. I don't need
them all. I mean hell the whole family.
But I give them to friends
if they want him to. Yeah,
just they just started laying
the eggs recently. But yeah,
we had people over this weekend
and we gave him some fresh eggs.
It tastes delicious too. Yeah, cause
we give the chickens like vegetables,
like we buy vegetables,
like say I make Kale shakes pretty much
every morning and it's cucumbers and
Kale and celery and fruit
and stuff like that.
So a lot of times you have like leftover
stuff left over Kale and leftover.
And we feed them that and then we feed
them chicken feed and they wander around
the lawn and they basically eat anything
they find that tried to heat your house.
They're stupid. Stupidest Shit. Peck
at your house, you're like, hmm,
maybe this house is edible.
They did is checking everything for food,
but they've become like our
pets. You know, they're not,
they're not chickens that we're eating,
we're just getting eggs out of him.
But it's amazing how
much you get out of them.
They give you food and that food is based
entirely on food that you give them.
So it's just this process.
It's like a natural healthy
cycle and nobody gets hurt.
They're happy when they see ya, you
know, there's no cruelty involved.
And so for me it's like I just
started doing this really recently.
We started growing her own vegetables
and raising her own chickens and not as
like a doomsday prepper sort of a thing.
But just as like,
let's see what this is like. You
know, my wife's super got into it,
so it's been really fun.
It's been kind of cool.
What vegetables you grow all sorts
of. Um, we grow a hot peppers,
we grow cucumbers who go tomatoes,
we grow squash,
we grow lots of different things
that you can eat kale. Uh,
we haven't started doing that yet, but
that's the next step. You know, Kale, I'm,
we're,
we're trying to move our little a garden
to a new spot and we have this new area
we're going to set up. It gives a lot of
sunlight and the idea is to just, uh, the,
the best idea I think would
be completely self sustaining.
We're going to go solar power too. But
one of the things we found out is like,
solar doesn't help you if the power
goes out. You still need a generator.
And I was like, that's stupid. That's
so dumb. Like how is that possible?
Like the guy explained to me
at the soccer boys go, I go,
so if the power goes out
we're still out because no,
actually you have to have a generator. And
I go, what? What are you talking about?
What does that mean?
It doesn't make any sense.
Like somehow or another there's gotta
be a way to have a completely standalone
system, but uh, it's, it's not that
easy. I think you have to have,
cause your house is still connected
to the grid is that maybe could be,
I mean it maybe be completely
removed from the grid maybe.
Oh yeah. I would think that would be
the smartest thing anybody could do. No,
it's not that I'm a doomsday prepper.
It's at like,
I think to be self sustainable would
be ultimately what I want to do.
These are my beginning steps.
Ultimately what I want to do is get a
bunch of friends involved and buy piece of
land, build houses and have a farm on it.
Not a cult. Just get like a few couples.
Sounds a little culty,
a little call culty everything I do
is a little culty but I, I, I do,
it's a fine dance but my idea is to um,
have a,
a large plot of land,
you know,
like several hundred acres with a few
families and everyone sort of have,
uh,
this big space that's their own and we
share it and like a community farm and
that everyone gets their food
from there that way. See,
what I'm weird things about neighborhoods
is that you don't pick them,
you sort of just, you pick where your
neighborhood is. Of course, if you can,
if you have that freedom but you don't
really pick your neighbors if they're
there when you, we, we liked this house.
We like, you know, Manhattan beach,
let's move in.
And then you're moving into a bench around
a bunch of people that you don't even
know. Whereas the whole idea
of community and culture and,
and tribes used to be that we
lived near all of our loved ones.
We had them all together.
We don't do that anymore.
It's kind of rare
playing the lottery game.
Get a day as you often
do if you won the load.
And that was definitely on the top
of my list. I'd buy a big house,
but that I could be lots of houses around
and I could move all the people I love
around me, my friends and family
and yeah. Well I've actually,
we've actually sat down,
uh,
our family sat down with a couple of
other families that we really like and we
actually started talking
about doing that and uh,
where we've decided to make
some, uh, have some meetings,
have some dinners where we meet and
discuss the idea and look at like various
locations whether or not be feasible with
all the people that they all have sort
of alternative entertainment type jobs,
like comedians and writers
and stuff like that.
And so we're all just sitting there like
what an awesome community that would be
into til the live in a place where you're
in a town where there's a, you know,
like a, a good town, like a healthy
place with city that's close by,
but set up an establishment where you
could grow your own food so you don't have
to worry like is this organic or these
grass raised is this farm, you know,
farm healthy and clean. It's your own
farm and it wouldn't be hard to do.
And if you think about how much
money you spend on food every year,
it seems to me that if you have quite a
few people hiring some really competent,
nice people to run a farm for you,
while people would appreciate a good
job where they work for nice people and
everybody's ethical about
the whole situation and how
everything's done and fair
and you set up a nice little
community farm. I said,
I don't think that that's impossible.
That doesn't seem like a a big dream.
That seems like something that's
entirely doable, you know,
and a new reality show. Yeah,
that's where it all goes.
Well, it seems like you'd get to need
some money for sure. You need it.
Need some money to set up almost anything,
but the real problem would be you'd
have to planning and you know,
you'd have to get permits to build houses
and or you'd have to buy a bunch of
houses together,
which is he even more ridiculous and
how are you going to pull that off?
That would be hard,
but I just think that ultimately that
seems like it would be the ideal situation
to get all of your food that
way. Not all of it. I mean,
he's still go to the supermarket
and buy mayonnaise and some shit.
You don't want to sit
around making yourself,
but how beautiful would it be to not
worry like, okay, the power goes out.
Well guess what? We have power. Okay. The
supermarkets are empty. We have a farm.
We get all of our food
from this with this area.
Then you just have to worry about the
other people. Yeah, you shit hits the fan.
Chickens. Crops took this to a doomsday
place. Again, that's what I do.
Try to stay positive, um,
guns and six episodes. So any,
any other interesting topics.
And we did one about homeless youth where
we actually spent a lot of time with a
young people who are homeless
out here in Los Angeles.
And we spent a couple of nights sleeping
under the bridge. Oh. Oh my God,
you did? Yeah, we did
both of you together.
You live in La,
you know,
it's like driving downtown or Hollywood
and you see all these homeless kids and
sometimes adults in. Did you guys go
to skid row? So we went to skid row.
It starts off in skid row and um,
you know,
we explained that place
for people who don't know.
Good row is the largest homeless
community in the nation. That's, I mean,
uh, thousands and thousands of homeless
people. Yeah, it is. I mean, it's, uh,
sleeping on the streets
in tents and know they've,
they've tried various times to clean
it up. Um, but, um, it's, you know,
there's a lot of issues there. It
was like, where are you going to,
where are you going, how's them?
Um, and there's a lot of, um,
housing and there is a lot
of shelters down there,
but not enough to sort of meet the
demand of how many homeless people were
actually down there. And so if you go down
there, um, day or night and you'll see,
you know, uh, hundreds if not thousands
of people walking the streets, um,
you know, with their carts and
it's, it's just, um, another, uh,
side of the city that, you know, you, you,
it's actually right next to the archduke
shut shutdowns downtown. And so it's,
you know, it's sort of, you, you, you,
you've run across it here and
there if you're living in la.
But it's definitely a and eye open
experience and walk down there because
there's a whole ecosystem
down there that, um, sort of,
uh, caters to not cater is probably
not the right word, but you know,
like that is a s supports,
um, the homeless down there,
um, from, uh, you know,
clinics and shelters and stuff like that
too, obviously drug the others and uh,
and gangs that sort of run the
territory down there because, um,
as the activist who we fall
down there told us, you know,
it's not just the homeless community,
it's the,
probably the largest concentration of
addicts in the, in the country as well.
Because most people,
obviously if you're living on the streets,
you're either dealing with
the mental health issue or a,
some sort of addiction or
both. Um, so, um, yeah,
we've,
that was crazy
was, it was fairly eyeopening I'm
sure, to see the population, right?
It was, and it was, it's the, the,
the idea is that if you are sort
of above 35 and you're homeless,
you're on skid row. If you're under 35
and you're homeless here in Hollywood,
and that's even more sort of surprising
because you think of Hollywood,
you think of the walk of fame,
right?
You think of all the stars and celebrities
and then you know for us who live
here in La and we drive by the Hollywood
every day and you see all those
homeless kids every day and you know
that they're sleeping out on the streets
and this,
again because of mental health issues
or addiction or just because they come
from broke, broke up, broke down
families and have nowhere to sleep,
which was some of the cases
of the people that we filmed.
And so we decided it was sort of important
if we weren't really going to dive
deeper and deeper into this issue
to spend the night with them,
two of the people that we were filming,
I would have faked it. I did it just like
that dude. The what? Not Survivor man.
Who's real les Stroud.
Who's the other guy?
The fake guy who's English dude?
Uh, some bastard. Their bedroom.
Yeah.
He sleeps in hotels.
Oh yes he does. He got busted. No Way. Yes
he did. Yes. What I like is that when you,
I can't really describe it. Go ahead. I
like that. It's all you're always like,
and now I'm here in the middle of nowhere.
You can't see I'm,
you know that there's like a big camera
and a camera guy and everything. Filming.
Well that's one of the beautiful
things about Les Stroud.
There's nothing but him.
He brings cameras and a backpack.
He does everything himself.
He sets up the cameras.
He even has videos of him up the cameras
so you could see him when he walks off.
Like he would walk a hundred
yards in the distance of films.
He has to go back and get the camera and
then take it and put it a hundred years.
[inaudible] I'm a hundred yards forward
and have him walking towards it.
Like he sets everything up from south.
It's very time consuming and survivor man,
survivor man is the real one. The the, the
other one bear whatever the fuck it is.
It's Horesh wild total horse shit.
And the reason why that show was created
was because Les Stroud wouldn't play
ball with producers and set up fake shots.
They wanted to like,
oh less stumbled upon this dead
animal. This is how you, you know,
fix this dead animal so you could eat it.
This is how you meet or cut it up.
Bear Grylls does all that stuff. So
he's like, you know, he would do it.
He would fudge shit and Les Stroud. So
the only way to do this is to do it real.
Yeah. So he like will starve. He'll be
out there for five days with no food,
you know,
and really freaking out and not knowing
whether or not he's going to get out of
there and trying to figure out how to
alert the crew and how to start a fire
when it's raining out. Like all that
stuff is real. When you watch that show,
he deals 100% of it, which
is, it's so fascinating.
When people found out about
the other show, the bear
Grylls show, they were like,
get out. Fuck that Guy Sleeps in tents.
No, come on man. He's out there for real.
They'll hotels. Really? He
really is in a four seasons.
Oh Man. Like he's pretending he's covered
in mud to keep the flies off your face.
You got a smile on your face in
mud. No mud dude. He in a mud mask.
He's getting a feet massage.
Pretending he's out there.
It's fake as fuck. It's
totally fake. You know,
like this one found like a dead sheep
and he like turned the, she like,
like the clothing out of it.
That's probably fake too.
Um, you know, I don't know.
I would assume he's not
taking his own pen. I mean,
if you're going to fake everything else,
why wouldn't you fake drink home?
I hate to admit this, drinking my own
piss. I'm drinking my own piss before.
Well because someone told me that,
um,
there's a thing called in
therapy and he said that why?
Like this is a person who has covered
investigative journalism for her whole
life. She's seen horrific
things. She's been to the,
the oxycontin center of the world.
I would tell her,
check my own people just immediately like,
what is wrong with you?
Um,
can you leave now several athletes and
have a thought that it's a good thing to
do that somehow or another
you get vitamins that pass
through your body and then
you recycle them in your urine and
that your urine is sterile and it's not
nothing to worry about.
And it's actually antibodies and you're,
it's very controversial. But I had
done it to see if there's anything to,
like when I was sick,
I took a drink,
my own p for times and I
don't know whether it room
temperature right out of the
hatch, right into a cop and
down the old pipe. It's more,
I don't recommend it.
First of all,
it was really clear and I
don't do it all the time.
I've done it a few
times once on the radio.
I'm just cause I wanted to it
cause I'm not squeamish. Right.
I hosted fear factor for six years.
Right.
I know what's bad and what's not drinking
your own urine. Even if it's terrible.
It's no big deal compared to some
of the shit that I've seen face.
I've seen face to face. People eat
horrific things and not just once.
I've seen it hundreds of times.
So it's like for me drinking my own pee.
Oh God. Animal Dicks, urine
24 ounces of donkey come.
I saw people drank donkey semen. That was
what got the show canceled actually. Um,
they had a drink,
donkey,
semen and the TMC got ahold
of the video and got unlocked.
It got online before the show aired and
then a NBC pulled the episode first and
then cancel the whole
show. That was, yeah,
that was the second run
season. A fear factor. The
video's online. Can we take it?
Yeah, exactly. Well that's the thing is
that that was approved by the network.
That's the most fascinating aspect of it.
And when I say by the network,
I should not say by the network,
I can say some executive that decided for
the network. That's what I should say.
Whether or not represents the
cooperation of NBC as a whole.
I think that'd be misjudging it cause
they pulled it when they found out about
it, but someone thought it would be a
brilliant idea to make people drink come,
you know they say like,
Oh seems reasonable as it's,
well it's not going to kill
me. Oh yes. Not just one.
Three people drink it. Yeah.
There was three. It was twins
and three groups. Twins.
The video is actually available online.
You can still get it because in other
countries they didn't censor it in other
countries,
fear factors and all the,
everything in the air like more
than a dozen countries worldwide.
And they are in other countries.
That's customary though.
That's actually one of the ways that
we got it passed really New Zealand.
Um, one of the things about
fear factor is if we ate,
especially during the first season, if
anyone, if we aired people eating things,
it had to be something that
people ate in other countries.
So like insects are very common.
People in poor countries eat
insects all the time. In fact,
insects are probably eaten more than
livestock and a lot of countries. Um,
so that was an easy one. We
could prove that. And then, uh,
in New Zealand they started selling
shots of horse, semen at bars,
like as a novelty. And
people would, uh, you know,
Mosey up to the bar and
buy a shot, a horse, semen.
And apparently they said it gave him
energy and all sorts of crazy things were
attributed to it. Most likely
placebo faculty, I don't know. Um,
but they even have a good story
afterwards. He got to justify it somehow.
Somehow or another, you've got to
say, listen, I know it seems crazy,
but I feel awesome.
I drank that whore.
He's probably so freaked out
that you drank horse come,
you don't know what's going on in
your body. Your fingers are tingling.
You can't feel your feet even know
what the fuck you just did. Um,
so because of that, NBC said, well,
the people are serving it and there's,
there's uh, we brought them a new
story, not we, and it was not my idea.
I should stress that.
And so that allowed them to sign off on
people drinking 24 ounces of donkey come
24 hours. Yeah. It was ridiculous. Not
only that, how about the contestants? Uh,
he at least had a shot
at winning some money,
but we had PA's drink it and they,
they only did it because it was part
of their job. Just the friends of them,
they got like a hundred bucks.
No, no, no. See if it can be done.
Whenever do we do a stunt on fear factor?
There was several times where we'd look
at a stunt where there was a physical
task or whether it was something,
some someone eating something.
We had to figure out what's the correct
amount and whether or not physically a
task could be completed.
So the,
the physical aspect was handled
by stunt man first of all,
who would look at it and say,
well you shouldn't do it that way cause
I don't think the guy could do that.
And if he does do that, it's
probably gonna hurt himself
in this way or that way.
And then with the eating thing, this
really only way to find out you got it.
Like how many bugs can I person
eat? Hmm, let's see. Okay,
we'll try to get a phd 10 and then
let the PA would have like 10 minutes.
He 10 bugs and they'd be like three bugs
in just rolling. And you're like, okay,
this is too much. Let's cut it
down to five or you know, we'd,
we'd have to make it some
sort of a reasonable amount.
So you'd have to have more than one pa
because you want to have a control group.
So you know, those a few pas and
I hope you pay them really well.
I would give them extra money. I would
give them extra money all the time,
especially the horrific ones.
I don't remember how many dollars I go.
Several hundred dollars. I gave one
of the extra pas, but that's nothing.
Several hundred dollars the fuck man,
you just strike to calm.
You know what's really making a note here
that next time have a PA complaints to
us. I think we should tell
them about fear factor. Yeah.
Being a PA socks for a lot of a lot
of places. I mean sometimes it's cool,
you know,
but for the most
park not good. We were offered, actually
we didn't eat. We off. We were offered um,
monkey brain in the Amazon, but
that's it. The time remembering.
What was that awful? It wasn't
the break, it was just monkey. No,
it was a monkey head. He cut
off the monkey, the hills there.
And then what was it that you, you ate
that I hated that had all those hairs.
It was the little hairs. The, the
Armadillo of the Amazon, the Tattoo,
that tool.
And it's an Armadillo and Amazonian
armadillos. Hey, spelled tattoo.
T. T. U. T. No, I think that to you.
Maybe I should know this, but I know,
yeah, you should. What's up, just like,
Hey, I'm from Portugal. We don't have
thought too is in our, my country.
Oh, but port is um, the Brazilian
Portuguese or same everything.
Same. Yeah, like you don't,
there's nothing. No confusion.
And there's some words here
and there are different,
but not English and American.
I went to talk to all this.
This is what Darren is. There it is.
Whoa. It's an ugly looking thing, right?
How do you spell that? It tastes like
it looks g. T. U. T. A. T you. Wow.
What a creepy looking thing.
It was awful. It tasted,
I mean worse than it looks like
there's also a Russian music duo of pot
Russians called tattoo tonight to you.
And there's always pictures of them.
Like
good touching. Yeah. I didn't mean to.
But the thing is that when they've
never, when we eat, the meat,
hair is still there,
so they sort of burn.
They don't take the hit.
So it's slightly burned from the
barbecuing of the meat. That's it.
You can still taste it and it tastes
awful. It really does. But they love it.
It's a delicacy there. They did. They did.
It just tastes terrible. It tastes,
it tastes like, uh Oh. What's that?
Oh Man. What's this stuff? Um,
three tribes. Tribe, tribe, tribe.
You really, yeah. I like 'em udo. Uh,
yeah. I log my noodle. I like tribe and
Menudo and organs and all that stuff.
It's a little game. Here is a place in
boulder, Colorado called the pop who says,
Oh man, we should go there all the time.
If you ever, if you're in boulder, it's a,
um, I guess it's not Mexican. It's
a Spanish food. Maybe it is Mexican.
Pupusa as though they have the most
sensational menudo. It's amazing.
It's all like hearts and Oregon's
and liver and tripe. Sounds terrible.
It's fantastic. It's fantastic
stuff. Super legit. Yeah.
Like that with this one place, it's
like so good. Spicy and like, oh,
they say it's hangover cure.
I think it's just so good.
You forget the fact that you're hung over.
Right.
So what I've had in other places,
and it's nasty,
like I had an a place in Atlanta, it
tastes like shit. It's all about doing it.
It's definitely tasted like shit.
That'd be, it wasn't, it wasn't good.
I've had menudo and then maybe
it's not a fair comparison. Well,
if you live in the middle of the Amazon
you got here, what were you going to,
he was there. Right? Do
they eat those copy borrows,
those crazy big rat things
to eat those things. It must,
I mean it must and we saw a couple of,
we didn't get in but we saw
the copy virus everywhere.
I think anything is theirs is open.
It's open season for whatever's there if
you're actually need to survive there.
Um, yeah, the crazy shit. Do they jaguars?
Well, probably not there. Hardly there.
It's actually really
hard to see it like that.
Like I think most people that come in
contact with them is, it's too late.
It's too late. Yeah. They're
like really stealth predators.
You know, I was almost attacked
by a Jaguar. Really? So we went,
we went to do the story on the Campbell
frog looking for the pharmaceutical
pharmaceutical promise of the Amazon.
And we went in with two herpetologists.
These are guys who study
poisonous amphibians and
snakes and they go out every
month. They go out for a week at
a time and they go deep, deep,
deep into the Amazon.
I mean they take a canoe deep inside
where there's nothing around and they said
that we,
after much haggling,
they decided that they were going to
take these two gringos along with them.
Me and Darren and we are camped
out in the middle of nowhere.
There's nothing there's we put out are
we bought, we bought a couple of um,
hammocks.
We hung them as soon as we got there
and then at night they go out with these
lights,
with these headlamps to look for the
most dangerous and most venomous venomous
snakes and frogs they are on in the world,
in the middle of the Amazon.
It was a crazy,
crazy experience,
but for some reason because we were
filming it and we were on this high of
filming this documentary and how cool it
would be if we found the most dangerous
thing in the world.
For us it was,
we didn't feel like scared
and we thought it was great.
We were filming all this crazy stuff.
We got back to the hammocks at night and
I'm sleeping on the edge because they
decided they wanted to
give me a little privacy.
So it was a sort of like little wooden
camp thing and I, but no walls, no roof,
nothing,
just these hammocks.
And I was on the last hammock right on
the edge and in the middle of the night I
woke up, nobody told me that in the
Amazon it gets really cold at night.
So we had nothing to protect us
and we had these mosquito nets.
And middle of the night I, I heard,
I woke up because I was freezing.
And then I heard and we'd been talking
about all the stories they've been
telling us, all these stories on the,
the, the all side they call it, they also,
they are and how the, it's the most
dangerous animal in the Amazon.
And suddenly I start hearing it,
a hearing,
breathing right next to my head and it
was breathing in is breathing really hard
and I could smell it, I could
smell. It was a big creature of big,
hairy, scary creature breeding right next
to me. And I had one of those, you know,
when you have those dreams and you try
to scream and it does, nothing comes out.
That happened to me.
I panicked and I was trying to call out
for Darren or for the other guys and
nothing came out.
Like I was literally frozen,
panicked and Darren woke up with my
breathing because I was breathing really
heavily and really scared and he asked me,
are you okay?
And I was able to get out just,
and Darren comes up to me and uh,
I told him I was about to be
attacked by an author by a Jaguar.
And we went around the camp with the
lights just so I could see that there was
nothing there.
In the morning after I wake up,
I look at my bag and it was full
of hair, full of hair. And I said,
I told you I knew it. I knew. And I
told the scientists that were with us,
you know, I saw, I know it was a
Jaguar. I was right next to me.
And then we looked around and there was
a freaking stray dog that had come from
like an Indian reservation calls
by Ann had been the stray dog.
Oh.
So it would have been a much,
sorry if it was a Jaguar.
It was the scare of my life
for no reason.
Just smell of death.
The mosquito netting is just a dream.
I am terrified of big cats more than
anything on the planet. They're there.
So I have cats at home, like little cats
and I just watched the way they move,
I'd jump on, we feed them on, they're
all, they was eat on the counter,
which is the equivalent of me jumping
on the roof of this building. I mean,
it's not happening, but to them
it's like bullying. They just,
they just hop up on
the counter and eat it.
It's so crazy to think that there's
one of those that's 200 pounds and it's
black as night and it's
wandering the jungle.
Yeah, it's, uh, that's what I was thinking
about when that was breathing heavily.
And
what is the,
what kind of poison and stuff did
you guys find when you're out there?
Bushmaster awesome. The snake, not the
gun, not the gun. Um, a lot of things,
but you know,
ultimately we were afraid of all
these things and actually Darren has a
fascination for, for snake. So
he wasn't as scared as I was,
but what got us was several
months after we came back. Um,
I had this little thing growing on my
finger that I thought it was just a bug.
And then I decided I had to get it
checked out because he was growing and
growing and suddenly possible
was coming out of it.
So I thought it was maybe skin cancer.
And I went to dermatologist and
turns out I got a flesh eating Perez.
Couple leishmaniasis that I caught in
Brazil only exists in a few parts of the
world. So they didn't have
the treatment here. So by CDC,
the Center for Disease Control had to
make a special treatment for me. That was,
that had a nurse come to my house
and, and it was, it was pretty scary.
That's why I say fuck going in the
air. I hear stories like that. Um,
it's near that or what does that show
the enemy inside you or something like
that as a show that it was always
about people going to these places and
catching parasites. Uh, yeah.
They don't realize they have them
until they crawls across their eyeball.
They started having weird behavior because
there's like a baseball size cluster
of worms growing inside their head.
I wasn't that sure you
scared nature is very scary.
So this Wednesday is the show and it's
on Nat Geo and it's called inside secret
America. 10:00 PM this Wednesday.
Set your dvrs. Watch it.
I am going to, I can, I'm running
home. I'm gonna set my DVR.
This has been an awesome conversation.
I really,
really appreciate you guys coming down.
And again,
I really appreciate that oxycontin
express that really opened my eyes to you
guys and also to the subject at whole
and I think it was just brilliantly done.
So I really can't wait to see this.
So national geographic or it's nat geo
now's or they're calling themselves or
being slick. Wednesday, 10:00
PM inside secret America.
Thank you guys very much. We
really appreciate it. Thank you.
Also to onnit.com go to o n n I t and
use the code name Rogan to save 10% off
any and all supplements.
Thank you also to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com four slash Joe
and you use the Code Joe Seven to save
yourselves from car song on crime
and thanks also to audible.com go to
audible.com forward slash Joe and get
yourself a free audio book and 33 30 free
days of audible service.
Uh,
we will be back tomorrow with the
Great Joey Coco Diaz, a k a mad flavor.
My little buddy red ban will
be joining us again as well.
He's off doing his own podcast tonight
at the comedy store with the Great Tony
Hinchcliffe they're doing when
they're on a regular basis.
You could check that out at death squad
dot t v and that's get you out all
Brian's podcast there as well as his
new t shirt that he's releasing. He, uh,
he just got done designing
it and he's got a presale.
It's available now on desk squad.tv.
All right.
We love you guys and we'll
see you tomorrow. Thanks
everybody. Big Custom home.
My Mama.